Hunter Biden has been indicted federally
wow uh it's not the first time I guess
there's that other plea agreement that
he's currently working on but more
charges related to guns and uh
interesting to say the least considering
the investigations the impeachment
inquiry into his dad and what this will
end up meaning for the 2024 election
because all this stuff happening to
Hunter does leak out into the Biden
family in the Biden Administration and
it is all connected there's a tweet from
Michael Tracy saying you know what are
they really going to impeach Joe Biden
before he did a decade ago
and rep gosar said no what we're seeing
with Ukraine and with the war is the
ongoing bribery or is is connected to it
so this is this is pretty interesting we
got other really big news Kevin McCarthy
rips a report to shreds and it's it's
masterfully done and I'm not even a
biggest fan of Kevin McCarthy but the
reporter is implying there's no evidence
and he just outright starts listing
things he's like Joe Biden did this
didn't he he did right okay he did this
right okay he did this right okay he did
now all of these things are facts yet
the media keeps saying no evidence so
we'll talk about that in a bunch of
other stories my friends before we get
started head over to timcast.com click
in the menu bar timcast irlx Miami and
pick up your tickets to our live event
in Miami we hope to see you there we got
Donald Trump Jr Patrick Bet David Matt
Gates Lou gradkowski we're going to be
doing the IRL show live on stage for
those that are coming with a bunch of
free stuff for you there's going to be
an elite members meet and greet earlier
in the day we got a pre-show we got an
after show you don't want to miss it we
hope to see you there but don't forget
also click join us become a member if
you'd like to watch the members only
uncensored show we will have up for you
tonight at 10 pm these actually go for
about an hour these days maybe about 50
minutes and uh uncensored not so family
friendly but we actually take calls from
you our members when you sign up as a
member you join our Discord server where
there's a big community of of people who
are like-minded there's pre-shows
there's after shows as a member we
choose one member's company or project
to shout out on Fridays so that could be
you
you want to join the Discord just for
the community stuff that's fantastic
you'll also get access to the members
only show and you can submit questions
call in the show live it's really
awesome and a shout out to all of our
Discord members for all the really cool
stuff they're working on together with
their pre-show after show the projects
they've built together the things
they're working on it's it's really
really amazing stuff
so don't forget to also smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show right now if you really do like
it and joining us tonight to talk about
this and a whole lot more is Katie Faust
thanks for having me good to be here
absolutely who are you what do you do uh
my name is Katie Faust I run a
children's rights non-profit called them
before us which looks at every marriage
and family and reproductive issue from
the perspective of the best interest of
the child and I have a book coming out
in two weeks called raising conservative
kids in a woke City because my husband
and I have uh four kids largely
teenagers one college Age kid and we uh
largely raise them in public schools in
Seattle and they are awesome in Seattle
in Seattle baby you must know some
secrets to we're insiders rebellion of
the Beast people yeah I got it all for
you right on so so not immediately
political but I think later on in the
show we'll definitely start getting into
more of the family social and cultural
stuff so thanks for hanging out should
be fun great to be with you we've got
Hannah Claire bremelo hanging out hey
I'm Hannah Claire I'm a writer for
timcast.com I'm really excited for this
conversation and it's uh good to be here
Ian's here too I am and I agree with you
both you guys I think the Nexus of a
nation's political health is the Nexus
of is the family health so kids it is
man it's the way kids interact with
their parents it's just the beginning of
everything so good show's over yeah
that's where we're going to land it is
all right we'll catch you tomorrow
I'm actually just kidding the show is
just beginning so stick around and check
this guy out yeah onstars.com let's just
uh get into it all right here's the news
from timcast.com Hunter Biden indicted
on three federal gun charges a judge
denied a plea deal previously offered to
Biden by U.S attorney for Delaware David
Weiss and the story being by Hannah
Claire I'll just ask Hannah Claire
what's going on
uh so Hunter Biden has had a long and
lengthy legal path so these charges are
uh one count of a false statement in
purchasing a firearm account of making a
false statement relating to information
required uh to have a federal firearm
firearm license and
um one count of possessing a firearm by
person who is uh using or addicted oh
wow they got him on drugs yes so the
thing is under Biden is open about the
fact that he is addicted to drugs right
and we'll all remember was was
um I think the alcoholics say it's it's
forever but maybe no you're divided yeah
um so he uh
has had tax charges levied against him
and you'll remember that about 12 weeks
ago he pled guilty to tax charges he was
going to not go to jail and the gun
charges and a judge about six weeks
after that threw out this sweetheart
deal that was offered to him uh by the
Attorney General in Delaware and we all
remember this it was a reminder that we
have a two-tiered justice system in
America which let Hunter Biden get away
with a sweet deal and potentially have
immunity on all kinds of stuff uh and
that was thrown out and I think that
that's a credit to everyone who spoke
loudly about how they didn't like it I
think what was it like two
whistleblowers came out and said yeah
Hunter Biden's doing this but they're
not going to go after him because it's
it's the Biden family right and so uh
there was a lot of outcry online there
was also uh the House Republicans
launched an inquiry into this deal to
see how the uh Merrick Garland who
appointed Weiss and uh just generally
how did they sign off on this plea deal
you see I I just want to point out you
know when timcast.com does a headline it
just says something like what Hunter
Biden died in done on three gun charges
I like I I you know we try to just be
base basic and just give you the
information you want to flash your
headline I look at the Daily Mail Route
Hunter Biden dead on three felony
charges for lying about being on drugs
when he bought a gun but that's is that
accurate because not all three of those
charges exactly exactly but that's a
heck of a headline yeah I mean and and
you know if you said Hunter Biden
indicted on felony charge for a lot for
charge for singular for lying about
being on drugs when he bought a gun
that's a pretty good headline that that
that hits yeah and if you're trying to
get people to understand the severity of
what it was
Hunter Biden is doing in the worst of it
this is it right here I I do however
think I think this might actually be a
distraction
when we had Brianna Wu on the culture
war and I brought up Joe Biden flying to
Ukraine to get a prosecutor fired at the
best of his son Brianna kept saying okay
so if Hunter Biden did something wrong
he should go to jail like no no not
Hunter Biden Joe right if Hunter Biden
something wrong I'm like no no stop I am
not talking about Hunter Biden
this story right here it's flashy a lot
of people want to hear about it oh what
did Joe Biden's kid do yeah but he
bought a gun while he's on drugs first
of all I have questions about the Second
Amendment and whether or not if you're
actively on drugs and you're like out of
your mind yeah okay you can't have that
that makes sense you can't keep you
can't have a gun and you're like waving
it around or something but I'm like if
it's in your car and you're on drugs is
that a big deal you're not gonna be
driving right it's about wielding and
and being in control of the object but
also I'm not so convinced it's just
because you're a drug user you shouldn't
be allowed to have a gun but I don't I
don't you know through due process
perhaps but but that's that's a whole
other argument ultimately my point here
is
the question we should be asking is
about Hunter Biden calling DC saying
we're being investigated by this
Ukrainian prosecutor Joe Biden then
flying out and what relation these
things have to each other and how they
came together
this may be intentional I would not be
surprised if Joe was like look we know
that the White House sent that letter to
all those media Outlets saying
scrutinize the impeachment don't let
them do this I wouldn't be surprised if
if Joe was like Hey indict Hunter on
some non-political thing so we can push
the new cycle away from the things I was
doing with Prisma and all that stuff I
think you're totally right I think
letting him fall for some things
headlines to be oh no he is facing
Justice and and the average American who
is not as well versed in the complicated
uh goings-on of the Biden family really
aren't that complicated they lies
personal gain and they lied about their
foreign business interests will say oh
well Hunter is facing charges he is he
is having to own up for things this is
okay uh and it's a way of sort of
circumventing actually facing the
reality that if Hunter's guilty it Joe
is definitely guilty yeah I get the
feeling that people are turning on these
guys now this Biden crap and like we'll
pull it up I think at some point in the
show there's a video of someone on CNN
just rattling off lies that Biden's told
including that he went to Ground Zero
the day after it happened CNN's
admitting it yeah wow
the Biden family couldn't keep hunter in
the background for long enough they
tried so hard like I don't remember if
you remember the Democratic National uh
convention when he was running for
president they brought out every single
granddaughter they did not bring out his
grandson and they did not bring out
Hunter they are trying to pretend like
there are no males in this family
because being abiding male I guess
except for Bo is not a good look well
you get Bank though right aren't you
making bank I mean his brothers his kids
yeah and they love the force and the
unstable family it's just great
I just want to say
Politico wrote this long magazine story
about the influence peddling of the
bidens in 2019 called Biden Inc huh
and today four years later the media
says there's no evidence and I'm just
like do you read the news apparently
they don't read yourselves they don't no
the greatest thing is easy for someone
to say that something that they don't
see doesn't exist I just I just found
out his name's not Hunter Biden what is
his name Robert Robert Hunter Biden yeah
and his son is something similar I'm
looking at it they they posted a picture
of the gun form
and his name is Robert yeah he's Bobby
Biden why are we calling him Hunter
Bobby it is
that crazy that people go by their
middle names maybe that's a controversy
but our hunter Biden you gotta put the
initial first he's named after one of
Biden's Brothers right there's another
Robin okay I think I could be wrong it
hit me last night and I I knew I knew
this but that Hunter had started
sleeping with his dead brother's wife
while he was still married yes we
started cheating on his wife with his
brothers yes and I think she so the
story behind him having his gun there's
this uh cult I didn't know what guns are
called Cobra and he apparently bought
the gun and his girlfriend at the time
Beau Biden's Widow uh apparently threw
it in the trash can in the story to like
pass it away from him next to a school
yeah with them were they both like drugs
no but I really feel bad for all these
cousins whose Granddad is Joe Biden the
sniffer and then this is their parents
set this does not seem good I mean it
has the parenting expert in this room do
you advise I do not advise no no no no
this is none of them making sex tapes
with your husband and when you're an
elected Congressman I mean none of this
none of this well actually so I have a
question for someone who is a parenting
expert uh
I think I said it before I think I think
Hunter buying got molested ah I don't
know it's a pretty heavy subject but
when you look at what Joe Biden's doing
on camera to these kids that it's that
and that Hunter Biden has reportedly
referred to as dead as Peto Pete then
you look at the substance abuse and the
behavioral issues I'm like that seems
indicative of someone who's abused as a
kid uh I don't know but I will tell you
this uh if your kid gets some drugs
involved in drugs all bets are off all
bets are off I mean I've seen so many
good parents who better parents than me
right who have lost their kids because
you know One Toke one smoke so you're
saying that Joe's actually a good dad no
I am not I am saying that I am saying
that if you've got a drug addict uh I
just know a lot of parents out there
that feel really guilty because their
kids have substance abuse issues
um and and that's a problem with
substance is it controls you you know
and there's not a lot you can do to get
your kid out of it so I don't know about
the molestation issue
um it's interesting though because
Hunter has a substance abuse issue and
so does his sister Ashley Biden has has
been in rehab a couple of different
times and so there is obviously
something going on family I know people
say like addictive personalities can run
in family but sometimes addiction is a
response to trauma now what oh that's
true 100 True 100 yeah I don't know what
it is um as the old man sniffing is he
just too close is that last generation
with oh honey come on here I don't know
I don't know what it is or is there
something going on he's got like anger
rage under the surface that butt Joe
Biden so that is 100 True like you can
see him anytime you get you something
gets in the way and you know there's the
eruption yeah I'm looking at like a
reporter questioning him right now about
uh flying out to Ukraine and and Biden
being like no one warned me about that
she's like they warned your staff he's
like nobody warned me that what I was
doing was wrong
um and I use that dementia too though I
mean like I guess I guess he's been kind
of like flying off the handle ever since
he was elected in 1920 or whenever he I
don't know
1840 right right but also like that is
why aren't people looking at that and
saying mental decline dementia that is
what happens when you get slip into
those those kind of things there I think
some people are saying that just not the
people in his immediate care you know
what I'm saying I don't want to assume
that he beat Hunter up or like squeezed
him too hard or pinched him or any of
that but I can definitely visualize it
like grab and be like you can already
when he's like nine years old and 14 and
stuff Hunter calls him pedo Pete yeah
really I wonder what Joe Biden here was
one of his make his son call him that
that was his one of his aliases was Pete
Peter yeah Peter what was it uh um I can
find it Robert Peterson
because obviously child abuse is such a
serious topic on the other hand I have
maintained for a long time that there is
something deeply troubled in the Biden
family and I think we just get more and
more evidence of this all the time
I wonder what it must have been like for
like you know Don Jr
you know growing up with Trump as your
dad he talks about it pretty positively
I mean I've had a chance to hear him
speak privately about it and also you
know with his mom their Heritage I think
they're chuckle Slovakian also
despite the fact that Trump has been
married three times all of his children
seem to be close I mean they all
attended Tiffany's wedding you know they
seem to have positive relationship with
each other and with you know Melania
different step parents the Biden family
seems openly much more strained and I
don't think it's a good look that you
left your wife or your brother's window
I could only I could only say this Peter
Henderson if only he left her he
actually just started cheating on her
was it Robert L Peters
a couple times he's been on the show
we've talked to him on the show on the
phone we've had him here physically I've
met him at events he just comes off like
a regular guy well Don nothing like
there's there is no
he comes off more like a regular guy
than
people who have like become successful
and gotten famous that I know or or like
he comes up he comes up like a regular
guy more than some regular people
actually know yeah when you look at the
hunter Biden stuff this is like
Lifestyles of the Rich and the and the
drug addicted the rich and the
congressman because yeah Joe is probably
only at home three days a month grow for
boys in Congress for 50 years or
something 28 days a month in in
Washington he was sorry I was gonna he
was famous for saying no I take the
train home to Delaware every night which
means
that's worse if you were a congressman
who does have access to your children
regularly and your children don't feel
like you're getting the support that
they end up in these complicated
emotional states if he's coming back on
the train he's getting back at nine at
nine pm at night so that would have been
my guess like if there was something
Askew if we don't if we if we don't have
our finger to put on oh it's absolutely
abuse or whatever it probably just is an
absolute father hunger right that they
did not get the connection that they
were made for from their dad because he
was off I think you know whatever and it
sounds like Trump in some way even
though he had these marital breakdowns
he was able to file accounts stay
connected to his kids and meet that need
for male love that his kids craved from
him and that all kids crave from their
dad yeah I think when you look at the
problems of Hunter Biden and you look at
the stats on kids who grow up without
dads there's like a correlation there so
we're going all the way on that tomorrow
yeah yeah so culture work okay you'll be
for cultural in the morning to talk
family stuff more in depth but uh you
know I'm like drug abuse this this is
like no strong Father Figure or abusive
father who like an abusive father is
also not a strong Father Figure in it
and it plays into it and seeing multiple
siblings going through the drug abuse
and that's it's interesting right I mean
it's not I wouldn't call it a
coincidence at least value and usually
there's some thread to tug on some need
was not met there was a need that was
not met and really they lost their mom
and their sister was that it yeah like
that's freaking that'll rip a family
apart if you're not able to communicate
about it he got sworn into Congress from
the two boys hospital room gee wow
that's nice I mean there's a reason a
his story I think caught the attention
and I think he did build a political
career off that but did he build it at
the at the expense of his children's
emotional well-being yeah I don't know
right did they lose their mom and their
dad oh man that's what happened to my my
parents my my mom's mother and father
lost one of their kids my mom's sister
when she was 10 got hit by a drunk
driver and killed and they just receded
into alcohol is on the parents and they
were basically left to fend for
themselves growing up their oldest
sister kind of raised the kids so that
can absolutely happen just one yeah but
let's talk about that father of his Joe
Biden we got the story from the
post-millennial speaker McCarthy
demolishes AP reporter over false report
that house has quote no evidence for
Biden impeachment inquiry this video is
absolutely amazing let's uh maybe I can
pull it up on Twitter make a little
bigger uh bigger here let's uh let's
play this clip it's a minute and a half
long and it's Kevin McCarthy talking to
an AP reporter I believe is an AP
reporter what impeachment inquiry is to
do is to get answers to questions are
you concerned about all the stuff that
was just recently learned
do you have any concern
have you asked the White House any
questions yes okay
do you agree that
do you believe the president lied to the
American public when he said he'd never
talked to his son about business
dealings
yes or no it's all right I can't answer
that you can't answer that
do you believe when they said the
president went on conference calls do
you believe that happened
that's what the testimony says do you
believe the president went to Cafe
Milano and had dinner with the with the
clients of Hunter Biden who believes he
got those clients because he was selling
the brand okay do you believe Hunter
Biden when he saw the video of him
driving a Porsche that he got a hundred
and forty three thousand dollars to buy
that Porsche the next day
do you believe that three million
dollars from the Russian oligarch that
was transferred to the Shell companies
that the bidens controlled after the
dinner from Cafe Milano took place
for the testimony okay then I go back do
you think the president lied that he but
is that an impeachable is lying and
impeachable what you want to know I'm
not saying impeachment all I'm saying is
I would like to know answer these
questions the American public ought to
know and that's what impeachment inquiry
provides so the first thing I'll say is
don't call calm down everybody
news organizations do hire
developmentally disabled individuals to
report the news and I know it may sound
funny but it's true
this woman doesn't even know what she's
reporting on slow down there stop
laughing I am being serious
she is not reporting on an impeachment
Kevin McCarthy did not say we are hereby
impeaching Joe Biden he said we're going
to launch an inquiry which is we will
begin to bring together information to
ask ourselves the question should we
impeach
so when he points out all of this
evidence and there's so much more and
she agrees it all exists yes yes said
that yes it said that but that's not
impeachable
Kevin McCarthy is like I'm not saying
impeachment she doesn't even know what
she's reporting on Welcome to the the
modern American Press it's it's sad
because it feels like there are so many
intelligent people and even average
people who just actually watch the
videos and look for the evidence to
understand it better who are trapped
living in a world where you've got a
news media comprised of people who don't
even know what the story is they're
covering and they're friends and their
followers who go and vote
that's what I see when I look at that
I'm like oh there's the two Americas
there's the two Americas we're like I
hear everything that he's asking I'm
like oh yeah I heard about that I heard
about that oh I know about that but you
talk to my friends who are on the left
and they're like what are you even
talking about like Joe Biden has never
what I don't know what you mean hunter
never did that the hundred doesn't do
that did Hunter even own a gun I mean
like we are getting no like we are
getting two different sets of two
different history two different language
you know two different lexicons two
different reports I mean like we have no
way to even communicate because all of
us on the right know all of these things
and nobody on the left knows any of
these things probably because uh
reporters are like no I'd like to uh
give an analogy it is you see your
friends on the left the people we know
many you see one day they woke up and
they were on this uh uh
on this ship where a giant monster with
a squid face put a tadpole in their eye
and then the Elder brain took over their
minds I'm making a Baldur's Gate
reference to everybody who has no idea
what I'm talking about I thought you
were doing like the biblical like spec
in your eye logging Brothers whatever
amazing yeah the uh the opening story to
Baldur's Gate this is not a spoiler it's
literally the start of the game is uh
the Mind flayer it's a mind that
controls you and it infects your brain
and mind control you and so these people
are quite literal figuratively trapped
in this world where they have this
machine this broadcast tower telling
them what is or is not true and these
people cannot they they do not have the
willpower to ask themselves a shout out
to Brandon strzok who he's the he's the
founder of walk away he tells this story
and there are many people have had a
similar story of how he broke the Mind
Control he says that you know he saw uh
Donald Trump the thing with his arm
where he's making fun of the disabled
reporter someone told them actually
Trump wasn't making fun of a disabled
reporter and he's like what are you
talking about I watched the video I'll
prove you wrong
and when Brandon finally decided to
start investigating it turns out Trump
mocks everyone in the same way and the
the the actual evidence the video that
was made to debunk that claim is
on numerous occasions Trump would insult
someone by going oh look at me I'm so
dumb one time one of the reporters had a
disabled arm and they Twisted the story
to make it seem like Trump was
intentionally mocking his disability
instead of it just being something dumb
Trump does Brandon said he had like this
this harsh moment where he actually felt
pain confusion like wait this can't be
true this can't be real what am I seeing
imagine
just one day you wake up and everything
you believe is wrong dude it hurts it
does it's suicidally painful like I
almost killed myself when I found out
about the liberal economic order fiat
currency the the military industrial
conflict 2006 when I got this washed
over me and like this one thing to learn
about all this stuff when you have no
knowledge and this is just how you're
learning reality it's another thing that
to unlearn 20 years of data what did it
for you like what shook you out I mean
what what was it learning about the way
that Banks can issue infinite amounts of
money or near infinite amounts of money
with Fiat what does Fiat mean it means
faith we have it's not even backed by
gold like I was told I thought our money
was actually at Value it doesn't has no
value what triggered you to like look
deeper war in Iraq 2006 George Bush when
I found out there were no weapons of
mass destruction I'm like what okay now
let's go a little deeper 911 I saw the
buildings fall in free fall I'm like
well they told me that planes knocked
them down why are they falling without
support the entire buildings that uh it
was like thing after thing after thing
and then I'm like why are we in two wars
in the Middle East all of a sudden when
only one of them is is involved with our
attack all of it was very strange there
there are there I got more there are
three great examples from 2000 from the
2006 area-ish that I think were you know
shocking to a lot of people the first
was loose change you ever see Loose
Change no give it to me so it was a
viral documentary Loose Change 911
second edition it was it was second one
that went super viral and it's
essentially insinuates a conspiracy or
cover-up around what really happened on
9 11. I am not saying that the
documentary is true that they've
actually issued a bunch of Corrections
there's a lot of speculation I'm not
issuing an opinion on that but for a lot
of people to watch something like that
it changed their perspective on what the
news was telling them and this resulted
in uh you know for me for instance I'm
working at O'Hare Airport and they play
this this video for like you know we're
watching it sounds like you got to watch
this and I'm like what was it like some
guy brings in the break room and I'm
skeptical on everything but it did make
me think like was this really in the
news like these things they're they're
referencing because that's not what I
heard and then I wanted to read more and
more about it to be fair though I had
been on online most of my life so you
know I'd been well connected to I I've
always been reading things but for the
people around me that was like all of a
sudden they were getting a different set
of information the next was Zeitgeist
and Zeitgeist moving forward these were
two big documentaries at the time uh
around this period And I think it was
moving forward which explained fiat
currency and fractional Reserve banking
this went viral as well explaining to
people how your money is nothing how
they can just Mass produce it tricking
you into working really really hard for
no reason and then you realize you are
living in a house of cards
that documentary comes out and then just
give it a minute the 2008 crash happens
a lot of people got smacked in the face
and this shattered trust I'm not saying
these documentaries are true and correct
I am not saying that 911 the loose
change video is true and correct I'm
saying for a lot of people it shatters
their worldview yeah they might not have
all true data in all those movies but it
was enough to get me inspired to start
researching that stuff well you know if
if those two documentaries did that for
a handful of people because I never
heard of that kova did that
to scores of people right because you
know it's it's a little hard to quantify
all the stuff going on with you know
currency manipulation or fabrication or
whatever's going on you know I hear
about the 911 conspiracy I don't know
about that but you tell me that I need
to wear a mask from the entrance of the
restaurant all the way until I sit down
and then I can take my mask now I'm okay
and that is enough that is so close and
so tangible for enough people to go all
right F you have you seen the meme where
it's a guy standing up and kovid is
coming at his face yeah he's saying that
it goes over his head it's plastic
barriers between tables so you're fine
right right right I went I went to a
restaurant that it was a so you know in
Frederick the buildings are very small
they're old buildings and the restaurant
was very very small
and I walk in the front door and I'm
standing five feet from the seat and
they're like you got to put a mask on
and I was like I'll just sit down and
First and I'm like
I'm gonna literally say if I sit down I
don't gotta wear the mask right like
they kicked me out oh no or they I
should say they insisted I wear it I
refused and left I'm just saying like if
this if the
if it's like deconstructed your
institutional trust coven
so oh my gosh with so many people like
now even like all the moms in my world
they're like I will never trust my
doctor again and you are in Seattle I
mean that's that's significant this is
what happened to me I I went through
this phase of I will never trust anyone
I do not trust anyone and and this is
like I'm still reeling from that 15
years ago but like a lot of people I
imagine are going through that right now
with what just happened like with
institutions but who do you trust you
have personal relationships you trust
kind of I mean I I it wrecked me this
this this I thought I was the good guy
growing up I'm part of the Empire I feel
like one of the Stormtroopers and I'm
trying to like fix the system but the
Death Star is still heading towards
Alderaan I don't know what to do but
it's not so simple right so let's also
use a different pop culture reference
because it's always Harry Potter or Star
Wars we use Game of Thrones Game of
Thrones it was really good until the
last season I do but they had that uh
that Arc where uh what's her name
Daenerys Daenerys Daenerys Targaryen
I've never seen it so I don't know she
takes she takes over that City where
they've enslaved people and and then she
strings up and kills all the slavers or
all the elites and then one guy comes in
and he's like my dad was Elite but was
using his resources to save the slaves
and stop all this and you killed him and
like that's the Nuance of it you can be
in in the Empire fighting for good and
being principled and like no one is
perfect in every single way but you
don't have to feel like a stormtrooper
on the Death Star you know yeah you're
you're you're you know it's the woke
that won't offer Redemption we will
Redemption it's possible yeah but the
the lack of trust that I have now in my
personal life and More in political life
is really what I'm talking about yeah
sure I imagine people are going through
that so like I almost killed myself
legitimately in 2010 but like I didn't
because I had good family the people
that that are struggling right now how
do we help them come to terms with the
cognitive dissonance of like accepting
that some of like because I I'm
genuinely asking well well hold on there
I'm gonna pull up this here video clip
you gave to me earlier Ian this is from
Colin rugg on Twitter and it's actually
quite amazing he says CNN is now listing
out all of President Joe Biden's lies as
the New York Post and Washington Post
are also ramping up their criticism of
Biden weird how they all change their
tune at the same time here are the lies
CNN now let's talk about witnessing a
bridge collapse grandfather died days
prior to his birth Amtrak conductor
conversations being in New York that
after 9 11 being arrested in a civil
rights protest driving 18 wheeler
visiting Pittsburgh the Pittsburgh
synagogue where people were killed let
me just play the clip for you from CNN
I don't know if it's similar things but
he's sort of told some stories that
don't line up quite
like it has a pattern at this point of
either inventing or embellishing stories
oh come on breaking news from CNN
they're figuring it out times in one
speech last month alone he claimed he
had witnessed a bridge collapse in
Pittsburgh when he actually showed up
about six hours later he claimed that
his grandfather had died just days
before he was born himself at the same
Hospital in fact his Grandpa died more
than a year before in a different state
not not the same hospital
um and uh and he also repeated a
favorite fall story that I and others
have debunked over and over again about
a supposed conversation with an Amtrak
train conductor he was friends with who
was actually deceased at the time the
conversation would have to take place
and that's not all there are some more
serious ones in my view previously in
his presidency he claimed at one point
he'd been arrested during a civil rights
protest when in other versions of the
story he just said an officer had taken
him home from a protest he said he had
visited the the Pittsburgh synagogue
where worshipers were killed in a 2018
mass shooting in fact he'd actually
spoken to the rabbi but never but never
went
um and he's made a whole bunch of others
too uh he said at one point Republicans
like to bring this up he said said that
he used to drive a tractor-trailer used
to drive an 18-wheeler never happened
the White House later clarified he used
to drive a school bus at one point for
as a job briefly School Bus of course
not an 18-wheeler so whatever his
intentions whether it's you know foggy
memory about stuff that's going on
decades ago
foggy memory it's an unfortunate pattern
I love I love this I love that Colin
rugg said weird how they all changed
their tune at the same time
okay that's weird huh old conspiracy
theorists the media is working together
to protect the Democrats and Joe Biden
new conspiracy theory they're all coming
after Joe Biden at the same time because
they're trying to get him out of office
I don't hate it though as a theory I
mean I think part of it is
it's the same thing because they would
do whatever they could to protect him
and apparently he is the out guy now I
mean it is a sign that the establishment
that Joe Biden relies on to continue to
control the Democratic party and to stay
in the White House no longer wants him
which I think we've known for a long
time that's why he would say yes I'm
gonna run again and the DNC and his own
press secretary would be like oh they're
still mulling it over they're still
thinking about it I mean they were they
have been out of sync for a long time
and I think it's because Joe Biden is
declining and I think that they know
they can't actually get a second term
and Kamal Harris is unpopular I mean the
thing is Joe Biden has given us some of
the best lies the bold face lies from
this man there was one today where he
said he used to teach at University of
Pennsylvania do you think we have him
paying attention to your entire career
like when do you think where does that
come from because I've heard him say
that before that he taught Somewhere In
The Deep recess of his brain was he like
an assistant at John no something no
dude look 40 years ago this was normal
in politics and he would never get
called out for it only he stole that
speech from the Irish guy or whatever
that Irish politician I think it was
it's an MBA yeah and it was in the it
was in the 80s and he's like you know he
had he had basically drop out of the
race well they caught him for that yeah
but it's he never got caught with
anything else well so I feel bad like I
look at him and I'm like oh my gosh I
feel so bad because well he has been
lying and he's never been corrected and
so in his mind everything that he said
is true I mean like he doesn't think
that he's lying and that is the power of
like you know this like literally living
in one of the most iron-clad bubbles
anybody could be in because not only I'm
sure is this family reinforcing it but
all of the biggest mechanisms of
communication are validating what he
says or at least not challenging him so
why would you ever doubt yourself yeah I
asked this the other day he did
something it's possible to remember
because he does so much stuff but I had
said uh does he is this Dementia or is
he lying and it actually could be bold
right right maybe he is so used to lying
that now that he's slipping mentally his
lies are getting Bolder and less less he
doesn't have to hide them he doesn't
have to blend them in with them they're
becoming less cohesive and coherent well
consequences change your behavior and
there's been no consequences uh also
he's 80. he's thinking yeah and he's you
know what he's doing after he leaves the
press conference someone who works for
him is like Mr Biden you just told all
those people you were a teacher at Penn
State it was a Penn State University of
Pennsylvania University University of
Pennsylvania and he goes dumb Pricks and
then he gets in the car he's like make
it true see you later no I didn't and
then they're like geez he'll fire me if
I talk back to him no no it's it's it's
uh me I think Olivia was Little Miss
Sunshine could be wrong where the
grandfather is doing heroin and he's
like I'm an old man I don't care anymore
it's like that's where Joe Biden might
be at he's like he probably gets in the
car and they're just like well here's a
bunch of bad stuff you did and he's like
so what
he's like I'm past the average life
expectancy he's like this is my problem
this is y'all yeah no exactly I'll see
you later I mean that is kind of it I
can't imagine being his staff right now
and having to be like oh well what he
meant by I drove a truck was actually
that he drove a school bus and we all
mixed up the word for truck or when he
um when he was at I can't remember what
the event was but he was speaking
publicly and there was that
um uh congresswoman who had just died in
a car accident and he was asking for her
and they're like oh she was just on his
mind right it's not that he didn't
realize or completely forgot that she is
not alive anymore he was just thinking
about her like they will spin anything
they can to make this work but at
certain point there are too many loose
threads for them to weave a blanket out
of yeah if his son wasn't like uh uh
deviant I don't think I think they would
lie until he left office but because his
son is just so viciously erratic you
can't hide it yeah I'm like convinced my
favorite personal conspiracy theory is
that so uh Hunter Biden is married again
he's married to a South African film
director and they met and got married
within 10 days which I love romance too
but that seems weird and they have a
very young son and I'm totally convinced
of convenience marriage so that when
people Googled like Hunter Biden
youngest child that kid would come up
instead of his uh Navy instead of Navy
the one he had out of wedlock and he had
all this drama with like I think they
were trying to make it so that he was
like a nice family man and we don't
understand and there's so many
grandchildren you mix them all up
meanwhile abiding family was just
completely not acknowledging what was
happening until they had to like two
months ago and released a statement
through people
um do you know if they got a prenup he
and this new wife of his I don't I kind
of have one because I think they're
pretty standard when you have that much
money but I don't know for sure
What a Sad family yeah
I'm just like imagining what it must be
like to grow up there you know like when
I grew up it was pancakes in the morning
and mashed potatoes and and we had
Dominics was our supermarket and so we'd
have like you know crummy little T-Bones
but my family did what they could and uh
we'd go outside and play and I had to
come home when the street lights turned
on I could not imagine this family no I
mean look respect the traumas are awful
right losing a mom and a sister but
and outside of that it's like Arrested
Development I mean I have also lost my
mom at a young age and I have never done
crack cocaine wait what I mean like I'm
just saying it doesn't give you an
excuse you can actually be okay uh I
think that losing a parent is you know
and I can speak to it really clearly
like it it changes your whole life and
you you live with it forever but you
know I didn't I have I mean at least I
haven't made any money off of it the way
he has it would maybe be better if I had
it's interesting because you know when
you look at parental loss
um you look at things like divorce and
by a couple different studies will show
that kids suffer more post-divorce than
they do the loss of a parent through
death and a lot of that is because you
know you lose a parent to death my
husband's mother was killed when he was
16 and what happens is everybody
surrounds you they remember together you
mourn with them you're not alone in your
suffering right and actually it is
easier to get over and beyond that kind
of tragic loss than it is let's say if
somebody cheats and leaves because the
child internalizes that and says it must
be my fault right when the parent dies
they don't go okay well she she you know
Hunter didn't go okay my mom wanted to
leave me right but when you lose a
parent in other ways very often the
child will internalize it as I'm the
reason why is that I don't know I don't
understand well think about it like
when for example parents divorce let's
say it's a no-fault divorce and the
parents just go their separate ways the
child is experiencing the death of their
family now they don't have their mom and
dad in their home every single day
seeing both of them saying goodnight to
both of them they don't have 100 of mom
and dad in their world which is kind of
like a kid's food mother love father
love is like social emotional Staples in
their diet so uh now they're splitting
time or very often kids lose contact
with their non-custodial parent usually
their dad often within two years and so
they're kind of being starved of what
they need but for them there was no they
couldn't figure out why especially in
these low conflict marriages which is
the majority of no-fault divorces so the
kid goes okay this wrecked my life I'm
starved of one or both of my parents and
I'm suffering uh and there I can't put
my finger on why this happened they
weren't throwing plates they weren't
yelling at each other everything seemed
fine this was out of the blue uh it must
be me and most kids of divorce at some
point go I must be the problem you know
what my parents got divorced running
around when I was like 13 to 14. and and
I did not experience that in the least
bit and you know my parents did the
thing we want you to know this is not
your fault no I get it good I was like I
know it's not it's like you guys you
guys are just going you're arguing I
don't know whatever like I think me and
my my siblings were all like just
particularly pragmatic for whatever
reason did you stay in touch with both
your parents afterwards yeah my dad my
dad was only a couple blocks away that's
good so he was still coming over to the
house my parents still got along they're
just like my parents are both very
pragmatic reasonable fairly stoic yeah
so despite their arguments and uh uh
which led to divorce they were like
we're going to work together and
understand there's no point wasting time
fighting about things we're getting
divorce do what you got to do and don't
like each other but you know you still
had access to both and you didn't have
to deal with high conflict like uh being
the go between between warring mom and
dad or anything no no yeah not really
that's good I think uh my my
parents were just like there's no point
like it get to a point where and it
probably rubs off on me hey yelling
isn't doing anything for us so let's
just get divorced and then we'll
facilitate whatever we need to
facilitate in a reasonable and you know
like studious manner or not studies but
like stoic manner I'm glad that they
were able to keep it together post
divorce yeah that's what I asked because
one of them bounced and you never saw
them maybe then like years later you
start to wonder if I'm the reason like
if if you lose touch with one of them it
might not happen all at once basically
that's why I asked because like I I
can't
I can't relate to that experience like
my parents didn't just ditch me right
they got a divorce but my dad was a
couple blocks away and my parents still
interact with each other and everything
and yeah but I think that's not true for
a lot of kids
I had an experience where I was with
someone that attempted suicide and I
felt like it was my fault that was weird
to go through that like I really felt
like I was my like I was I could have
done something different and I probably
could have done something different but
it's not didn't make it like you you are
I like you deep feeler tender man all
good men are tender men I'm not kidding
all good men are tender men the warrior
poet you gotta have a big sword and know
when not to use it yeah but I mean I
just think good men break over the right
things
like when you're watching a movie and a
dog gets killed yes oh my gosh my
husband cries more than me yeah that's
like the one he's a good man the one
thing that makes me not want to watch a
movie if there's like a needless dog
death but that's why John Wick did so
well because those writers knew exactly
what they were like we're gonna make an
action movie where men cry and it's like
right when the movie starts like his dog
he was give it to him by his wife like
I'll kill him that movie's amazing but
if Sadness the problem is good to feel
it because it's like gets me back to
normal but if it derails me and I'm like
oh I give up because it's like it hurts
so bad I what's the point I don't want
to go through that again that's when
it's becomes like a a bit of a roadblock
no that's because you're not meant to be
alone like you need other people to help
you through that
oh yeah
well let's uh let's get back to the news
uh loving this emotional conversation
ladies and gentlemen uh I think Joe
Biden's gonna drop up I think it is fair
to say Joe Biden will drop out that's
that's that is a strong opinion I'm
having
Nancy Pelosi concedes Biden may drop out
of the 2024 race then laughs and refuses
to say if Kamala Harris is the best
running mate because this was I believe
this was on CNN Anderson Cooper is
asking these questions and when asked if
Biden is going to continue running says
there's any chance that Biden does not
continue running says I hope not it's
actually a possibility now
thinking about all of the scandals we've
seen so far
and impeachment
they need Biden to drop out they need
distractions for this and and and we all
know it I mean there's no reasonable
person not even not even the majority of
Democrats the majority of Democrats are
saying he can't run he's too old what
does that look like then like explain
the process then if he says I'm not
running so then do they do a primary do
they just appoint somebody what do they
do well depends on how can Spirit
conspiracy-minded you are if you would
say I'm low low conspiracy mind is Joe
Biden is Rife with political scandals
facing an impeachment which everyone
thinks is going to be inevitable and
he's too old the polls show he's too old
so Joe Biden will be asked Joe it's time
to to get a new a new team in here
because we're not gonna be able to beat
Trump off of your ticket that's the low
conspiracy mind and then Gavin Newsom
says if y'all are willing to have me
shakes Joe Biden's hand and says I'm
willing to to fight for this country and
then but DNC just installs him as the
candidate no primary or something Joe
Biden says look you know I'm an old
man and I think handing this off to
Gavin Newsom is the right right approach
and something like that and Kamala
Harris says that she's not you know she
she's done what she had to do and she
was here for for team Biden and she's
only team Biden and she understands that
if I'm not interested she's not going to
be here that's local conspiracy mind
seems
difficult to imagine something like that
high conspiracy mind is
powerful interests don't want Joe Biden
to run and want a clean path forward
which is not Joe Biden coming out and
just bowing out because that makes the
DNC look weak look at makes Democrats
look weak High conspiracy mind in my
view would be Joe Biden suffers a
medical issue Gavin Newsom runs out on
stage and starts giving him CPR saves
the life of the president and then the
media does this press tour of Gavin
Newsom the man who saved the President
Joe Biden can then say like after this
medical episode I don't think it is
appropriate to pursue this uh Kamala can
then say something like you know I was
here for team Biden and I'm going to
stick with him if he's bowing out I want
to make sure that I'm working with him
on whatever he needs to assist him and
we want to pass the torch to Gavin and a
new team or whatever and that's high
conspiracy I pictured the most cringe
Time Magazine cover of Gavin Newsom
looking off at an angle and it's saying
the man who saved democracy he has the
most plastic looking and then there will
be a tagline where it's like facing the
facing the collapse of our of our of our
democracy from fascist threats like
Donald Trump Gavin Newsom saved the one
man who fought who who Gavin Newsom
saved the man who saved the country and
in turn took up the mantle to save the
country himself something like that yeah
and there are and all these editors are
sitting there being like I can picture
it right here
are there any Pathways where Kamala
fights for a spot
oh yeah I mean there's a million
Pathways I'm just saying like
the the the reasonable approach
any smart Democrat we've seen the New
York Times The Washington Post both be
like Joe Biden probably shouldn't run so
when you've got the media saying this
stuff you've got the majority of that
it's like 70 some odd percent of
Democrats polled say he's too old to be
president
any any Democrat worth worth their job
is saying we can't run Joe Biden how do
we get him out of the race
and so I gotta tell you my my conspiracy
theory it's not really conspiracy I'm
just saying the best way to get Gavin
Newsom in and to get Biden Kamala out is
Biden is at a rally in California for
his campaign and then grips his chest as
a public collapse collapses Gavin Newsom
runs full speed under stage throws his
coat off checks his vitals provides CPR
Maddox come in Secret Service secures
the area
magically the TV cameras are told not to
cut away yep all the cameras they
normally would be all live so
it's in the buildings come down in free
fall it's a bit too movie-asked and
conspiratorial like but I gotta tell you
if there was like an evil Shadow
organization of unlimited resources
plotting how you do this perfectly
that's it because then Gavin knows him
is on the cover of Time Magazine the man
who saved democracy Joe Biden violently
saved this country in 2020 Gavin Newsom
just saved him like it writes itself and
then and then he Gavin do some sort of
press tour he's on The View he's on real
time he's on every nightly show and
you've got Anderson Cooper being like
Governor Newsom
what is it like to be the man who saved
the president and then Gavin's just like
look
I'm not here to be a hero I'm just here
to do the right thing that any good
red-blooded American would do when faced
with someone in need Define San
Francisco and then but this this kind of
story you know we were talking earlier
about your leftist friends your Lefty
friends who don't pay attention to
what's going on
you would go to them and be like yes but
in California there's human waste all
over the ground and they'll be like stop
insulting the man to save the President
right right it exonerates all his sins
basically it makes him this hero but I I
I would like to figure out what's with
Kamala in this scenario and we've talked
about you know maybe she would be
offered a position in the Supreme Court
or they could they could well this was
actually easy uh after Gavin Newsom
saves Joe Biden Kamala walks on the
stage on the stage and says uh I must go
now my home planet needs me and then she
just lifts off and down his face
I've actually always wanted to be
governor of California so let's just
switch things yeah she's like that is
that but that is the the most difficult
thing in trying to come up with how
Kamala Harris is is to bows out yeah it
could really be her saying that she
doesn't know if she can she was
committed to team biting because of how
much she believed in him and she doesn't
know if it if she's capable of or if
it's or if it's reasonable too and she
could do this thing where she's like
look she'd get wrecked by the feminist
for saying that though well no she she
could she she could say something where
she tries to look humble and say I I
don't know if I would provide enough for
a winning ticket I was with I was for
team Biden and that team is is
unfortunately broken by this incident
and I want to make sure we win this one
and you know there's questions about
electability and polling I I say the
demo the Democratic party show the
primary and find the best people for the
job it would come off as humble yeah and
and and look the polls show she cannot
win but she couldn't have a job in
politics in it I don't think she's ready
to to type it but I'm not talking about
the real world oh yeah I'm like the most
magical scenario yeah I think the other
one would be if she pulled Sandra
O'Connor and her husband is suddenly
mysteriously ill and she feels as though
she needs to go spend time with him and
just side steps out of politics because
the only problem with the one you
presented to me is that the feminist
will be like you're a girl boss you can
do anything what do you mean you don't
think it doesn't really matter for it
matters for her and for her Legacy
that's that's what she wants to be maybe
speaking to him maybe
she marries Joe Biden and then when he
gets sick she's like my husband needs me
Jill's listening she's like that one
step too far Tim no I have been in here
for too long I've been paying my debts I
think realistically Joe will not can he
will not give it up actually I don't
know he they can convince him to maybe
they can come in and sit him down and be
like it's not happening dude no you're
not gonna destroy our democracy Let It
Go you're a liability you gotta let it
go and he's got like nine guys around
them all telling him that he might be
like okay for the party I'll step down
maybe but then who's gonna be It's gotta
be Gavin I think he's too power hungry I
think he's yeah so he's got to be tired
at this point I mean he's 80 and he's I
I don't know I don't know what they do
to Hype them up every now and then so
that he's like firing on all synapses
but I just think most synapses yeah I I
don't know I don't know I just think he
he might be ready for a break maybe yeah
but he didn't run in 2016 president you
could have said you know I I've served
my moment and we're out we got away from
Big Bad Donald Trump and so now I'm
ready for a younger generation to step
in he could have said that he kept
saying we need younger people I mean
Mitt Romney just made this announcement
saying if I run again I'll be in my
mid-80s and I think young people need
Joe Biden could have said this he chose
not to and I think that's because he
doesn't want to give it up he doesn't
and if he runs again it's gonna they're
gonna make him debate the media or
they're gonna start insulting him and
calling out his crimes and probably
imprisoning him without media coverage
it reminds me of the conversations
around uh Dianne Feinstein and like how
they're saying you know all these
organizations again feminist
organizations in particular are saying
you know you did so much for us thank
you for your time we really wish you
would leave yeah they said similar
things about Ruth Bader gainsburg they
said you know there was a whole
conversation about whether or not she
should retire because her Legacy and
this and the other and they wanted
someone to be appointed under uh not
Trump basically and uh
that didn't work out waited too long if
they if buying if they make Biden debate
if he refuses to step down he debates
Gavin Newsom it's gonna rip the
Democratic party apart it'll shred their
ability to win an election I can't
imagine that having that kind of come
like con conflict within the party would
be good for their for their message and
then that would I mean obviously I think
they're going to take Trump off the
ballot in a couple of states and make it
so I can't win a bunch of people in the
Republican Party are going to vote for
him anyway and split the Republican
party all up too so we could end up
seeing like 20 for Vivek 32 for Donald
Trump 31 for Gavin Newsom 24 21 for
Biden like who knows should be crazy but
then I I would not be surprised if a
secretary of state in a swing state in
October of next year or or September
removes his name from the ballot and
says sue me maybe I should stop saying
that it will happen though because I
don't want to be black pilled and
encouraged that dis reputable or dis you
know just disgusting Behavior like let
the people vote yeah unless there's
actual legal precedent to remove him
um
you got you let the people vote they're
going to vote for him anyway no write
them in there's there are too many
voters that just check Republican or
Democrat and so if they take Trump's
name off the ballot and and it's not
here's another thing his his name could
be off the ballot in key counties we saw
Arizona this could be a trial balloon in
Arizona we know it is definitive it is
proven Beyond a reasonable doubt it is
fact it's in the news the wrong sized
ballots were printed on wrong sized
paper so the machines could not read
them they'll argue it didn't change
anything and that is the most psychotic
and absurd lie the machines are broken
at hundreds of locations of course that
changes things there's no question about
that but they're lying because it's what
they do
where was the remedy for these broken
bouts I I really don't understand like
if I was a judge and someone came to me
and said these bouts couldn't be scanned
by the machine I'd be like election
overturned done no question it's not I
like but all these judges are cowards
and and pathetic and they're weak and it
was like I don't want to be the one to
say it
yes it's because they're being ponderous
judges best case scenario they're
cowards worst case scenario there's
behind the no they're in on it deals and
stuff yeah if if we're supposed to have
an election and and the ballots at
several hundred locations are wrong or
however many locations that's it sorry
guys it's a do-over don't know don't
care it's your problem you deal with it
we will not have to have a special
election we'll determine what an
adequate amount of time is for
preparation for you but
the the state screwed up the election
process and it should not stand but they
didn't do that
so the trial balloon is good come uh
2024 don't be surprised if ballots are
printed on wrong paper or Trump's
smudged or not included on it and
they'll say sue us I was talking to my
Uber driver today uh very interesting
and just asking him lots of questions
and you know what's the problem in this
country oh we're so polarized how did
that happen Trump
and I'm like really you think that Trump
is just a one-word answer yeah no he
said and we have to get rid of him and I
said how do you do that also he's not
president right now so right but he says
better right and I I was just amazed um
I just asking last question we have to
give it how do you do that legally and
he goes well they're working on it but
even if they can't do it legally he just
needs to go and it was like it just blew
me away and this was a guy who was a
cult pretty sensible uh don't have no
response like no reason for you though
let's just say he has to go and then ask
why and they'll be like well you know
just because like you know the thing
like you know because you know and what
he said is because he's tearing families
apart yeah he's telling friendships
apart and I'm like you think that
started with Trump and he's like oh
absolutely so we will not have wholeness
in this country until he's gone that's
yeah it started when he was on The
Apprentice he was just wrecking family
if you illegally got rid of one of the
most famous politicians in the United
States before he's about to run for
president you would not rebind the
United States that would tear it to
shreds I don't know what this guy's
thinking that's it's a cult no he is
getting he is getting one half well he's
getting a narrative and and he believes
it and so that's the conclusion so
anyway if you're a judge with that
narrative and you have the power to do
something about it what are you gonna do
yeah I don't know I think it's difficult
I think there are people on both sides
who feel the division and want truly and
honestly want to see that healed on the
other hand it's very hard to reconcile
opposite sides when one of them is
saying
getting rid of trump is the only answer
in fact he will always have a political
Legacy in this in this country even if
you know for whatever reason something
happened he weren't to win the election
in 2024 he has already made an impact so
are you saying that it's there's no
turning back that because there really
is no ultimately getting rid of trump he
is already a staple in American politics
he made a huge impact on our history you
have to be able to heal the wounds
regardless of who was in in the Oval
Office yeah well anyway I argued look
I feel like the sea change happened with
Obama personally and that was when I was
not a political animal it wasn't well to
me that was the first time when I heard
the other side saying um it's not that
we disagree it's not even that you're
stupid it's that you're evil you're evil
right now it's your Nazis your bigots
you're evil if you don't agree with our
Progressive priorities and you know you
can have relationships with people that
are wrong or misguided or stupid but you
don't have relationships with Nazis yeah
but they're evil
who the the the elements of the left
that are pushing their political agenda
you have the malicious evil and you have
the banality of evil the people who
March in lockstep uh so I'll give you a
couple examples literally not everybody
is evil but when you have someone say to
me I think the general direction that
the j6 trials are going is good right
and I say Joe Biggs got two decades for
knock for allegedly knocking over a
temporary barricade and they say I don't
know anything about that but I think
it's mostly good that's the banality of
evil when it's commonplace that ignorant
people allow evil things to happen but
you then have the people who are running
the show the intelligence agencies the
prosecutors and the courts that no
there's no reason to give someone like
Joe Biggs two decades for knocking over
a barricade that's that's ridiculous but
they're evil and they want you to suffer
they want you to feel pain these are
people like you know the funny thing
about uh video games I made a joke about
Baldur's Gate
most people who play video games will
understand this there are many games
that have Karma systems where you can
choose to be good or evil and the meme
online is that whenever people try to
play the evil character it hurts and
they can't do it they can't bring
themselves to play the evil character
unfortunately for you some people have
figured out how to do it in real life
the guy who why does it hurt
okay so uh Baldur's Gate for instance or
I.E Fallout three
Fallout 3 uh has a uh
right when you come out of the in the
beginning there's a town that's that's
built around a nuclear bomb fall three
is a game about a post-apocalyptic bomb
that never went off yeah it's a it's
like a Megaton bomb and very easily you
can disarm it or you can trigger it to
blow up killing everybody and it just
does it feels bad it feels bad to be
like I know none of these things these
people are real but I don't I can't so
what you the joke is you save do it and
then load and having never actually done
it just to see what would happen but
there's a bunch of memes where uh I mean
if you read stories about these video
games people struggle to be the villain
in the game so it's like
um in Baldur's Gate I don't want to
spoil anything but let's just say I'll
give a really Bland hypothetical the bad
guy looks at you and says slay the
innocent person and you can choose to do
it and most people like I I can't I'm
trying to play a villain character for
the villain storyline but it just you
can't bring yourself to just watch this
scene where it's a representation of you
hurting innocent people so it doesn't
look like you do you look like yourself
okay and then is the person that you're
hurting do they look like a real person
be a goblin could be a unicorn who knows
it could be random it's still pretty
cartoony at this stage oh yeah but but
it's it's not that it's my point with
this is not to get into video games and
all this stuff it's just that it will
start to look very real though the
people who understand what I'm talking
about if you don't you know just just
try and imagine the scenario but for
people who've played video games and
know that you're like I can't bring
myself to be the evil character
there's a the guy in Virginia whose
daughter was raped or sexually assaulted
and he was at a hearing uh when a woman
yeah yeah and a woman said to him you're
lying that never happened and then the
school board lied and said it never
happened and he lost it he got angry
yeah the prosecutor tried to put him in
jail and he said she is the most evil
person I've ever met we are dealing with
these prosecutors
this woman in in Virginia
knows that a man's daughter was sexually
assaulted in a school
she knows they're covering it up and in
her mind she goes I'm gonna put you in
prison because they they get this sick
pleasure from just hurting people it's
an unfathomable I cannot understand it
but that characterizes a substantial
amount of people in what we would call
the culture War left whereas the culture
we're right certainly does have these
people too but it's an inversion there's
much less of them they're less tolerated
people don't like that stuff on the left
you have the banality of evil the people
who March in lockstep not asking
questions about why you put someone in
prison for 20 years and then the evil
person is empowered by the ignorant to
to torture individuals well you have to
figure out what your God is what's your
God and for some of them you know this
school board uh you know women on the
board or whoever's deciding that he goes
to jail she has a god her God is gender
ideology her God is you know ultimate
sexual and gender freedom and what what
do you do for Gods you sacrifice for
them right and so if that's your God
then there is no sound sacrifice that is
beneath you and you must do it to
appease your God but I I agree with you
but I still think we have to be careful
in defining what God is because they're
Godless no what I'm saying is what is a
god it's something worth sacrificing for
right what is it wow God is your
ultimate your ultimate aim the thing
that matters most to you in life and I
mean like a God will warp your reality I
mean I think that that's what we're
seeing with the woke too is like if you
lift that up it will warp how you see
the world that is what Idols do but I
want to clarify the definition right
yeah yeah God to me is the literal
definition of God a higher powerful
being Beyond us and our capabilities the
creator of all things they don't have
that they have a something that they
serve but but they but they don't they
they do not have that Concept in their
minds of a higher power it does not
exist they're worshiping but I I it's
it's not the same thing there is a there
is a plus one a negative one these
people are either blind and ignorant and
will just be party to the collective
unwittingly and useful idiots or they
they believe they are simply but a wet
robot and there is no truth but power so
they will wield it however they see fit
you you you ask these people for the
most part they will tell you there's no
God and nothing matters and then you
have many people who might say they
believe in God but are ignorant and the
banality of evil they are the
commonplace ignorant person who does not
want to know does not care to know but
will gladly March behind whatever they
think is safe that might be that might
be the case but they have a hierarchy as
Jordan Peterson would say a hierarchy of
values something has to be at the top
that something is going to be served
that something is going to have other
subordinate values but there isn't one
but there is what is it well it depends
right is it Gaia is it the Earth is it
the Earth that needs your sacrifices
because otherwise we're going to burn it
to death and therefore we need to like
go to zero emissions and then all of the
poor people across the globe need to die
because we're serving Gaia but now
you're talking about uh you're talking
about an infinite group of infinite
different groups of people yes everybody
has something that they are worshiping
and serving and I think that for a lot
of people it's sexual freedom and like I
have the right to do whatever I want
regardless of who it hurts I mean if if
sex your feelings your identity your
decisions if that's god well then we see
children end up being the sacrifice for
that some things get something you're
going to serve something everybody's
serving something and even the people
that are just going along why are they
going along because you're made to be
part of a community and that also is
what religion does for you right it
gives you a fellowship it gives you
community it gives you identity and so
these people are finding a God to
worship it's just destructive you know
and it often involves humans I just I
just again want to clarify the
definition there is a God and they are
not there lacking one so so you can say
that they have uh they have vestiges or
tenets but they do not have God they
have a lowercase G
they have a framework they have a a
caetic mass that's all it is there
there's there's no cohesion to the
ideology they've bounced around from
pro-war to anti-war they they at first
it was critical race Theory then
critical gender Theory there is no no
nothing you can pin their ideology too
because there is not one I've had this
argument with you know people like James
Lindsay like they're they're not
marxists they will support capitalism if
capitalism is part of the tri part of
their tribal nature there's no logic or
moral framework to anything they do and
I think it's probably because they are
Godless and so their God is their self
that's it right and if your God is
yourself that means you get to bend and
you get to change right that's it and
this is the ultimate original sin and I
mean I'm talking to you as if um
my husband's a pastor right I carry my
my Bible's right here I read it with
everybody that I'm with so I love God I
know God but I also know
The Substitute which is very very often
and what the enemy will try to sell you
is you are your own God and that is why
you can and like this this is my point
is is they don't like themselves and
there's there is there is no nucleus to
which they have adhered to so in order
for there to be a God that they worship
there would need to be a centralized
structure which there is not that well
so that is why yeah that is why people
that worship self are as Hannah was
saying before the show
more likely to be depressed you know the
ones that are being sucked into you know
all of the different maladies the social
maladies yeah I think there is a culture
within the United States and I think
globally too that says you know
ultimately your own needs and your own
desires are what should govern your
whole life and if you are completely
absorbing I mean there are narcissists
who have very low self-esteem right so
they hate themselves but they also are
completely obsessed with their worldview
and they cannot be proven wrong about
anything they have all the traits of
classic narcissism but also you wouldn't
know it because they're covert
narcissists they seem like they are uh
defeatist in some way and I think it's
true that there are so many people who
are lacking direction or meaning in
their life that they either turn inwards
and become obsessed with their own being
and validating their own feelings or
they look to be the Defenders of
something and so you'll get people who
say well I'm here advocating for people
who can't Advocate themselves I'm here
defending you know uh people who are
gender fluid and I've got to be an ally
and this that and the other they are
looking to represent something because
they are so lost in and of themselves
well that's part of what it means to be
human is you are called to something
greater and if you're not serving the
greatest thing you will find something
lesser to serve I I have a I have a you
know I thought it was a good question
you asked about the video game Trope why
can't why is it so hard for someone to
be evil I wonder if that's we should
actually do an experiment with that
actually test people and try and figure
out oh yeah especially as video games
are more realistic when you're in a
first person game and you can actually
feel the knife going into the thing and
you can hear the screen stop how do you
feel that nice haptic feedback gloves
that will vibrate and create pressure
when you do things in the VR haptic
feedback there's also there's also uh
controllers technology the controllers
have pressure resistance now so when you
are like pushing a door open in a video
game and this is much more rudimentary
are you in an entire suit no well you
could be yeah so we actually have the
full VR thing downstairs not set up yet
where you can actually stand and run in
place but in some video games they'll be
like a door the door's closed to open it
you have to hold down R2 which is the
back trigger button on the controller
and it actually resists your push
whereas normally it just presses very
easily the controller can actually
create resistance to make you have to
give put more strength into it so with
haptics uh I don't know about putting a
knife into something but it can it can
squeeze your hand and vibrate and create
sensation yeah but nobody that's not
common no it's gonna become more common
in these action games where it's so
realistic that you're actually it's
gonna feel and seem like you're killing
something for real like the pig will be
screaming and blood will be coming and
you'll be like having to step I mean
that will create psychopathy in human if
they have to if that's how they train
their their gaming is like they're
killing stuff for real like that's not I
I read a thread on Reddit the other day
from someone who made a villain
character in Baldur's Gate and it was a
really cool looking character like
glowing red eyes and like a crazy face
paint and they're like so I got halfway
through and like every time I'm faced
with these these challenges it's like
I'm just doing things I really really
don't like and don't want to play the
game like I can't do it but the game is
CR is created as such that you can do
the villain stuff or do the good guy
stuff or be the Rogue or whatever and
they're people like I just can't bring
myself to do it
I would love to do a test where you sit
people down and and make them give them
like a scene from one of these games
easily scripted with you know Oblivion
Skyrim or something or even baltur's
gate and then actually ask people their
background their age their income their
education level all of that stuff their
voting patterns I would love to see
voting patterns maybe we should do this
what do you think you would see I'm
curious I think you'd find Democrats
overwhelmingly being okay with uh you
know like let's I I think you would see
you would have there would be a tendency
among people who say they vote Democrat
with being okay with a bad thing
happening in the game to Sir to varying
degrees why do you think
based on the political world that we see
right now when I ask someone why is Joe
Biggs going to prison for two decades
and they literally say I don't care and
I'm like a human being is being
imprisoned by an oppressive state to
destroy His Life For What and they're
like so what like that's evil
that is evil is it a form of nihilism I
no it's evil it doesn't matter but if
they're like it doesn't matter that Joe
Big's got 22 years like is that another
aspect of nihilism yeah it matters right
it's it's utilitarian thinking versus
deontological thinking and
utilitarianism in my view has a tendency
towards evil there are certain
circumstances where you can say we're
faced with a difficult decision and we
are going to try and maximize
life-saving there's not much you can do
you've got two school buses about to go
over the edge of a cliff one's got a 10
kids in it one's got three kids
man you gotta go for the bus the 10 kids
and save as many people as you want you
can't make decisions on the individuals
of the other bus and this This lends
itself to the trolley problem but to go
back to uh Joe Biggs individually it's
deontological morality you cannot take
immoral actions against an individual it
matters more than anything that when it
comes to Enrique when it comes to Joe
Biggs and the other proud boys that have
been overly sentenced and the other
j6ers it matters the world that each of
these individuals receive proper Justice
and the sentences they got are
completely improper the fact that we see
Democrats celebrating the torture and
unjust rulings shows me the evil rests
more so not absolutely so if we were to
create a video game scenario where your
character sees a man holding a cat and
then the guy instructs you to kill the
cat I I'd be willing to bet that it
would skew to a certain degree probably
a small degree that Democrats are like
so what do it and Republican
do you think that it would be different
if it was I mean because like I don't
know the the people that lean left in my
life uh they don't have kids they have
pets so I think that they might have a
hard time killing them not that they'd
be like oh it's a video game who cares I
wonder if that's right dissociated from
like and they'd say who cares it doesn't
matter if it's if it's less about
political affiliation more about
nihilism uh versus Heaven because
somehow not having kids it's like well
what is there to live for really what's
the purpose and everyone says let's see
having kids how about how about this we
get a thousand
conservatives a thousand Libertarians a
thousand liberals a thousand
Independents and then you know to what
degree we can get communist socialists
you know fascists whatever and uh
you make maybe 300 of each encounter a
different scenario a republican is shown
a video a video game scenario where a
Democrat is holding a republican by you
know on his knees with a weapon and
instructs you to commit and act against
them
in the video game it's just a video game
it's not real life you're fine
then 300 Republicans are presented a
scenario where it's the Democrat on the
ground then where it's an independent on
the ground and then you see are they
more or less willing to commit are these
groups uh based on the political
affiliation of the characters in the
game be interesting I think this is a
great uh Research Institute to start for
Tim Cass University
imagine a scenario in a video game where
and I quite literally mean a video game
like Skyrim and you have the villain
let's say he's a demon quite literally a
demonic figure with Big Red Wings and
he's there's a man on his knees wearing
a Maga hat and it's like he's wearing
night armor and as a sword was wearing a
trumpet would the Democrat voter
be inclined to serve the devil master in
the game I was going to say it's sad to
think that someone will be more likely
to attack someone based or let someone
suffer based on their clothing but then
I was thinking about military uniforms
and I mean that's the whole purpose of
uniforms who to make suffering and there
were I think in like in one year alone
there were 800 instances where Trump
supporters were physically attacked on
the streets at random like at what point
does civilian clothing become a military
insignia a militant symbol I don't think
of it as a militant symbol I think there
there was this study that uh Teen Vogue
I think commissioned they published
about this week
um saying that the overwhelming majority
of men and women they asked them about
their red flags and green flags and
dating yeah so you wrote about that I
did write about that I read a book
nicely done thank you so much uh so what
I find interesting about this is because
it was mostly large it was largely
framed off of political stuff so uh the
overwhelming majority of both men and
women said if someone identified as a
MAG or republican that would be a red
flag but but men said Communists men
were more likely to lean towards
Communists still 55 of women also said
it would be a red tigercommons but men
fewer men thought uh someone identifying
as a liberal was a red flag than the men
that thought someone who believes in
astrology was a red flag I mean there
are limits to the political affiliations
and I think there are like I'm just
saying look wait hold on I say to your
point it is interesting to me that
it was they were willing to forgive
liberals more than they were willing to
forgive imagine service the way people
perceive your political Innovation does
I think impact how they these were red
flags it didn't say they would not date
it did not say they had disdain it said
it was a red flag that's it and I don't
care who the guy is if there is a
beautiful woman and she's got a
communist flag pin he knows he can
change her political affiliation no he
doesn't care about changing but deep
down he knows he can change he's just
like yeah the woman may see the guy with
the Maga symbol and be like I can change
him for sure but more importantly
anyone I gotta be completely honest guys
especially Trump supporters out there yo
if I'm not in the dating Market but I
just have to say like if I met a woman
and her whole identity was like I'm a
Maga Republican I'd be like that's kind
of like anybody that I think it's gonna
be super weird yeah even if yours are
Trump supporter just being like that
would be like Oh and it works the other
way too like more women were more likely
to think it was a green flag if you were
saying if you said black lives matter
right like but why why does that matter
in who you're dating well because
they're looking for political compliance
in a way that they find to be acceptable
women were more likely to want they
would value talking about politics more
than men did Men actually didn't care
about how often you talk about the
majority of men don't care about how
frequently you talk about politics uh
men were more likely to think it was a
red flag or a green flag if women drank
cow's milk over any kind of non-dairy
milk like women were not thinking about
this at all but people are about
especially based on gender they're
evaluating your uh political and and
cultural behaviors in these sort of
small ways and it gives you an insight
into what you're doing so I think this
study on video games actually really
fascinating I think it could be
interesting to see if people were more
willing to hurt people uh based on
political ideology even if it is in a
video game if there and you'd have to
find a way to like test out okay if they
were willing to have to interject I'm so
curious and hopefully you guys well you
probably have already seen it but let me
ask you each uh how often do you guys
think about the Roman Empire fairly
often how many times I mean per week per
day where are you at three times a week
minimum yeah oh man yeah just probably I
mean we talk about it on the show I see
clips of it and stuff which remind me so
I don't know if that counts yeah plus
like how many times does it come to mind
is my question the chosen keeps popping
up on my TV sometimes I'll watch like
literally all the time okay if I watched
something for two hours straight does
this just kind of thinking of it once
because I think about it for two hours
constantly so have you seen this The
Tick Tock where the woman is like oh my
God my husband thinks about the Roman
Empire like once a day yeah and I mean
like
the last thing about the Roman Empire
earlier actually so maybe it's more than
two times a week yeah I I was I was
watching a show earlier and it auto like
this is not me choosing to think about
it but the chosen came on and there's
romance
there's that joke that uh uh in a
certain age men have to decide if
they're gonna get really into grilling
or World War II history oh my god there
are things that men that's not a
question I was no no it's not even my I
texted my husband I'm like do you ever
think about the Roman Empire how often
he's like well about once a day yeah my
dad and older brother referenced the
Roman Empire my entire life growing up I
felt like number one I was not that
interested
yeah this is correct women women are
shocked to find this out uh so as much
as many women don't like fresh and fit
uh are you familiar with fresh and Fit I
listen to your cultural War episode with
my 16 year old on a road trip so we have
lots of lots to talk about yeah that's
actually how that's how we parent but we
listen to it and we discuss they mention
women don't have hobbies
and it's like it's a shocking thing to
men to discover and I was like in your
little uh this is something
so uh they said that when they bring
women on their show
and they say it's average woman but I
really do think it's like it's Miami
local women so they're they're choosing
from a select match but they say when
they ask women like what do you do for
fun they go what do you mean and he's
like what do you do for fun like what do
you do and they're like I I don't know
like I hang out with my friends it's
like yeah but like doing what like we go
out like but what go out what does that
mean where do you go and like what do
you mean what do we do just go out what
are you talking about like the women are
confused by the question well so men and
women are different okay and this is the
difference women form relationships face
to face men form relationships side by
side so it really is a it's a different
thing men form bonds doing things
together like going to war and playing
on Sports and building a shed women
don't need to do that Hannah and I sat
down before him were like just tell me
about your life yeah oh my gosh where
did you go you you reference uh Men Are
from Mars when we're from Venus when
John Gray wrote that one of my favorite
things that I read in it by the way my
dad kept recommending that to me uh
because he was like you just need to
know that they're not the same thing but
one of my favorite observations that
gray had was that men go to lunch to
talk about something they go to lunch to
be like we've got an issue we gotta talk
about this we're going to make a
business deal and women will go to lunch
to gather information right it's a
reason that like I have multiple female
friends I can be on the phone multiple
times a week for four hours because
there's just stuff to talk about man
there's yeah but it's people versus
things it's very different subjects
that's right chemical bonding has these
elements too like ionic bonding where
you guys would be interacting sharing an
electron bouncing it back and forth or a
covalent bond where you're sharing it
together then there's metallic bonding
where all the electrons are headed in
one direction we're all protons
witnessing it that's like the male
communication tactic is a metallic type
of bond we're all focused on it together
it's uh it's object versus subject so
yeah the meme is that when women take
pictures of objects it's a picture of
themself next to the object man will
take a picture of the object so uh this
is this popped up on Reddit
because a guy would be like hey just got
a new video game and it's a picture of
the game and women would be like look at
the game I got it's them going like this
holding it is it better to say instead
of that men communicate metallically
women do it ionically or however you
were saying earlier is it better to say
that the masculine forms so yeah the
masculine form of communication is
focusing on a thing the feminine because
it's not all always women that do the
feminine Behavior sometimes men are
feminine and women are masculine or they
embody we each embody both yeah so
because I do enjoy the the cross
communication you were saying women
generally do I do it a lot more than
normal let me just give you a Family Guy
reference when Peter goes to it he goes
to a clinic to get like medical tests on
him to make money or something I can't
remember the exact reason and they're
like we're gonna give you the squirrel
Gene and then it like he turns into no
squirrel and they're like we're going to
give you the Seth Rogen Gene that makes
you seemingly funny even though you're
not saying anything that's funny and
then finally they give him the gay gene
so Peter becomes gay and then he calls I
think he calls Quagmire or or Joe or
something and he's like what what you
doing and they're like what do you mean
you called me and he's like what you
thinking about what what are you calling
me for yeah like like for guys it's just
like what why are you asking me these
questions the one I see on on Instagram
all the time is uh girls like husband's
pretending to call wisely like the way
they want them to and it's just like hey
it's just on my lunch break like what
are you doing
oh my gosh did you ask Andrea about
whatever and it's the same the opposite
is girls will like it's infuriating to
women that if you have like a boyfriend
who goes on you know to golf with all
his friends and then you're like oh how
was it they're like it's great you know
how is how's uh Joe doing with Andrea I
heard that they were going through some
rough times he's like I don't know oh
they broke up I'm like what when I don't
know they have no details for you this
is what women live for but it's because
we serve different purposes in society
so our communication obviously is
different we're hardwired to seek out
different information that's why it's
good to have both people on the team
right yeah having different
conversations or Mom and a dead when
you're a kid
you get 1 000 then before us points good
job
how do we credit these points oh I I
just keep track okay that's okay that's
great it's like it's like Hogwarts yeah
you don't need to understand oh okay
it's your honorary degrees Yeah no I'll
give you whatever you need to just keep
cranking out these
wisdom you know and I beat beat Ian it
is I win but Tim cast university has a
house cub it's very complicated you'll
have to hear about it in our Research
Institute okay uh but I do think that
there is something really valuable to
acknowledging that men and women's
communication is different but that
doesn't have to be bad it just is one of
the reasons that I think monogamy is
great because you only have to figure
one woman or one man out yeah right you
don't have to figure all of them out and
get good at communicating with them and
learn to change your Communication in a
way that isn't emotionally satisfactory
you just have to figure out one person
and there's these there's these General
distinctions that are generally true and
then every husband and wife is going to
break the mold in some way so like I I
am very low emotion and it's actually
really sabotaged to my husband in a lot
of ways because he's a pastor and that's
a high shepherding High Counseling and
he's very very good at it but you know I
I'm like honey just give me the
information what do you need just get
right to it you know I don't have a lot
of time I'm gonna be here for another
five minutes we can have this
conversation I'm gonna continue roasting
these brussels sprouts okay but I just
need to just get this to me really fast
um and then he'll go to work or go to
church or he'll talk to somebody and
he'll go why did you choose this color
for the bulletin and the woman would be
like
yeah and so it's like I have I I'm so
kind of low emotional needs uh and and
generally women aren't they need a
little more hand-holding they need a
little more like building up and um so
he has had to unlearn some of what I've
taught him but yeah like we don't fit
into a mold there are personality
differences but there are also
generalities that tend to hold true do
you well women are communists and men
are capitalists oh okay yeah uh
Tendencies right so if you look at the
voting patterns I'm being hyperbolic to
a certain degree when you look at voting
patterns women over a monthly vote
Democrat if you look at a map of the
United States If Only Women voted it's
every State's blue except for one but
isn't that single women yes right yeah
okay and then if you look at uh only
male voters it's every state is red but
one the question about women voting
Republican is are women who vote
Republican more likely to get married or
are women who get married later more
likely to vote Republicans right so we
know that there's a correlation we don't
know if it's conservative women who have
more children because really it's not
marriage it's child rearing right women
that have more children tend to be
conservative or does having more
children make you conservative and I
understand the kind of communist
socialist thing because the only place
that socialism really is effective and
natural is in the family right that
really small scale yeah personal and
five yeah like unconditional commitment
you know you you do what you can those
that are have less still have their
needs met all of that kind of thing that
is where it needs to take place so I
understand that women being a little
more nurturing
social family-oriented others oriented
because we are uh that that would make
sense because then they take their
little like micro society and apply it
to the whole nation yeah I found maybe
you guys can confirm or deny as females
that generally uh the feminine uh when
if a woman complains she just wants you
to listen and understand whereas if a
man complains he wants a solution to the
problem yep I don't know if that's it's
not always every time but I'm wondering
if you guys agree with that because I
found it excessively successful in my
relationships I think it's a good place
to start uh I will say again that in my
relationship with my husband be I would
say literally because he's a good man he
is intuitive and he is uh very in touch
with what's going on emotionally with me
and my kids and so he is more
long-suffering when it comes to
listening and maybe because I'm really
really busy I don't have time for the
deep emotional rabbit trails that we go
down so I don't know if it's it's just
personality or if it's kind of stage we
are in life I'm so busy uh that I don't
have time for the deep emotional dive
and I I personally don't need it but if
you're a guy I would recommend
defaulting with yeah just listen to her
yeah and then maybe ask do you want a
solution or do you just want me to hear
you out did you guys
involve therapy raising four kids
instead of like was there ever like
external therapists and stuff that you
guys go to as a family or individuals
that helped you no well we did do some a
deep a deep marriage counseling about
four years ago like you know most
marriages go through a rough spot and we
did we had like a year or two where we I
felt more like enemies than friends you
just have to push through that kind of
stuff so we did have to do a very
intense marriage week of therapy to like
do our realignment but largely it's been
fine uh it's been great largely it's
been great between us and between our
kids uh in terms of therapy not therapy
but you've got to read good information
you've got to find other people that are
parenting well that are a few steps
ahead of you because you need that on
the ground Intel what did you do for
this when your kid acted this way what
when how did you talk with them about
this one I mean there are things that
you are not going to know unless you see
somebody else do it successfully and
glean their wisdom so you don't have to
reinvent the wheel how'd you find those
people at church go to church I'm not
kidding no I don't care I'm laughing
because it's why we had church for so
long correct whether you're registered
or not it's where people come together
and your community shares resources
knowledge information values and it's
been shattered that's right I know we
say that in our book uh you know our
raising conservative kids in a woke City
the entire last chapter is called find
your people like you might think that
you are the only conservative in Austin
or Chicago but you're not there are
other people that share your values
there at church and you know what I
don't care if you disbelieve that a guy
can live for 72 hours in a whale's
digestive tract I I it maybe you're
skeptical but do you want other people
that are going to fortify you and your
children and tell them that they are not
crazy for choosing not to wear the mask
with a little cutout for your French
horn go to church that is where you're
going to find those people so even if
you don't believe that the Bible is the
Divine inspired word of God you need the
people that are at church go there don't
go to a church with a female Pastor go
to a real Church how come what's the
problem with female pastors how much
time do you have we've got like three
minutes before we go to super chess what
well then let's just get this over with
uh
my next book that I'm going to co-author
with my husband is called headship and
it's why God designed there to be
headship that is not domination control
or chauvinism it's headship it's
leadership it's primary responsibility
in two institutions and it's not
government and it's not Academia and
it's not business it is the home and it
is the church men are supposed to be the
heads of those two institutions why is
that because those are the two
institutions responsible for human
formation and men are not optional in
the project of human formation and when
men are made optional they leave both
the home and the church and that's what
we've been doing I think one of the
issues we have a society is that
socially we've made it being a follower
is a bad is a bad thing it's a bad thing
to be a follower Jesus followed the
father and so what we have is
where everyone's being told you want the
followers right your social media how
many followers do you have there is
nothing wrong with being a follower I
follow several people there are certain
people that are famous that are
celebrities and I'm super excited to
meet and talk to there are people
excited to meet me I was talking to uh
meet Kevin
and uh one of the things I mentioned was
it is okay to be a follower and there is
honor and respect in doing so and this
This lends itself to you know like
feminists are like no I have to be in
charge all the time I I feel like a lot
of men don't don't think that way when I
would play video games with my friends
there was no leader there was only
leading so uh we would play the division
for instance it's a you know four person
four people team up and you play like
special agents going in and like
stopping bad guys and uh
we'd be like hey man you've done this
run before just tell me what to do and
it's like okay let's go and then be like
hey go there and stay back we're gonna
go in front I bet you got it there was
there was there was I did not feel
slighted or disrespected in any way that
someone was telling me what to do I
trusted them so I my view is kind of
like
why do we love dogs so much one of the
reasons is loyalty because the
unquestionable loyalty to you you know
they trust you and you trust them and
you have their best intentions uh and
they know that if they trust you you'll
take care of them and we love that about
them we mourn for for our for our dogs
cats are silly and they're funny but
they they're totally independent but so
now we have a society that says you're
bad for being the kind of person that is
willing to trust in a leader like
there's got to be a fine balance right
you need to be someone who pays
attention who learns enough but you need
to also surround yourself by people you
can trust and there's nothing wrong with
being a follower or being a leader both
have their their good components and
their bad components a leader has come
is nothing without loyal men and women
who are behind him supporting the vision
that he has and trusting and believing
in it you can also be a leader and a
follower at the same moment like uh Adam
sosnick who works with Patrick Bet David
on the pbd podcast he's an example of
someone that he's a follower on the pbd
podcast he's number two to Pat but he's
a leader in his own personal life where
he runs I think a Fortune 500 company
that he's the leader right right and you
need that that first follower phenomenon
where a really great leader is only
gonna not gonna go anywhere until
someone steps up and says I believe in
you I believe in him and then then all
of a sudden ever all these other people
will be like well if someone else
believes in them then maybe there's
something to him I'll believe in him too
and so it's a that's an important role
to be a follower so and that's the rule
that's what you said the word that you
said correctly is roll this does not
have to do with oh this is the smartest
well he's the most talented it is no
this is your role and in these two
institutions it is a male Only Rule from
God's perspective and this actually
aligns with a lot of the ways that we're
naturally wired right like we were
talking before about men um having more
connections between the back of the
hemisphere to the front of the
hemisphere in their brains so they tend
to be a little more driven more focused
more alert to threats that is very
important when you're at the head uh
women tend to have more connections
between hemispheres we can jump around a
little more easy we're a little more
wired for connection uh that we're works
very very well when it comes to
caretaking and socialization and those
two things happen pretty easily in the
home in the church leadership is harder
leadership is harder and we need to
encourage men to move into those roles
people need to get chickens deciding who
has to go wait because you you got to
watch you got to watch them you know the
rooster does the dude stuff you know
I'll tell you this every Friday we have
sushi and poker here at the castle so
tomorrow at once we wrap up the show big
orders who she comes in everyone eats
together and talks and then the leftover
Sashimi goes to the chicken coop what do
you think the roosters do when we throw
the fish into the chicken coop
they keep their heads alert and they
look up and watch as the girls eat man
and it's rough because we're like we
want the roosters to eat the fresh fish
it's very very good for them but they
just wait and let the girls eat it the
the boys are just like nah I'm good is
there any food where they will be like I
want that
some like
I'll wait until little Luke is like by
himself and I'll toss a piece of fish to
him and then he'll look down and very
slowly like look at it and he might take
a bite or look up the hens will run over
and not just annihilate it and he'll
just stand there the inverse of wolves
because I think with Wolves the the male
alpha male will eat first and then all
the other ones will protect the alpha
male while it eats I don't know if that
includes with wolves and I think it's
true with lions too there's a there's a
hierarchy of who gets to eat I don't
think it's necessarily just the the
gender it's like the Elder it's like
seniority or something yeah okay that's
awesome but it is really funny we had a
uh our old chicken coop we had a hawk
attack and we only had seven and Roberto
runs he leads the girls to the door to
go back into the because the coop is
fully covered and at a little door he
runs to the door they all follow him and
then he stands next to it and waits as
they all run in and then he goes in
behind him chivalry gender roles in
society we I know we're not going to
talk about tonight maybe you guys will
talk about it tomorrow on the culture
War too but I think that reason and I
don't want to make General claims about
women in power because a lot of women
have masculine behaviors and aren't this
but the desire to to nurture and mother
without children comes out in like HR
comes out and women in positions of
power and with money involved is they'll
try and parent their their employees or
I mean there's an overabundance of women
in nursing right and we never think
that's a bad thing except for every once
in a while someone's like we should have
more men because of gender equality same
thing in elementary school you have tons
of female teachings like why aren't
there more male teachers well because we
are wired for this yeah
female sewage you know treatment
Specialists if they're supposed to
nurture at the same in a position where
their real job is to fire the idiots and
hire the good people and and penalize
and and ruin the people that are messing
up that might be challenging for someone
that wants to make sure everyone's
healthy and taken care of naturally so
female judges actually uh hand down
guilty sentences less often and less
severe penalties right and that and it's
great to be a nurturer it's great to
have that kind of social awareness it's
great to be high in agreeability which
is what women are but when it comes to
Justice when it comes to gatekeeping and
protection no you don't want that
nurturing uh that nurturing role to take
over you ever see that video where
there's a dude being sentenced or he's
being like arraigned by a judge and then
the judge recognized him they went to
grade school together and there's her
she's become this judge and he's become
the criminal and she's like did you go
to this Elementary School and he's like
oh my God God and then she's like I
remember you I went to school with you
what happened you were so nice we were
friends and then he starts crying and
breaking down saying oh my God over and
over again I'm like you want to talk
about how you reduce recidivism that is
a man that that she she that video is
crazy she's she's being it's a real
video
it's on the internet but she may as well
have done the Indiana Jones Kalima and
ripped that guy's heart clean out
because that was probably the most
brutal thing that guy's experienced in
his life and if there's anything that
makes someone feel regret remorse it's
that kind of experience being like we
went to school together what happened to
you and then seeing a reflection of what
you could have been and what you've
become I hope that guy you know turn
things around well and then like that's
not to say that women do not have a
critical role to play in formation but
it has women have what my friend Glenn
Stanton calls a soft power to shape the
world it's not through this is right
this is wrong do this don't do this it
is this soft soft influence and that
actually is why you see massive Behavior
change in terms of work hours and
pursuit of different higher degrees
adopting more responsibility when men
get married their behavior changes
because I was listening to your fit and
fit and fresh fresh and fit with the
manhood right and you said well what is
masking what is manhood and the answer
is taking responsibility for yourself so
you can take responsibility for someone
else that is what manhood is right and
so it's important for men to do that
they can't become a man until they take
responsibility for a wife and they
change like sociologists call this they
have a term for this and it is that
women civilized men their behavior
changes in such a way and for the better
more pro-social Behavior more
responsibility and married men live
longer I can Define what it is to be a
man very simply
it is you're on a uh let's just say
you're in a nuclear power plant that is
going into lockdown
and the blast doors are closing and you
have to run up and grab the door with
all your strength as it's pressing down
on you and crushing your bones and you
have to hold it as long as possible so
that everyone else can escape better one
is being a man is working security for
Morgan Stanley on 911 yeah and making
sure all of your employees get out and
then once they do knowing that there's
still Tenors or so in there and rushing
back into that building to make sure
they get out and then no one ever sees
you again and Daniel Perry on the subway
protecting the women from the psycho guy
who's threatening everybody and puts him
in the responsible not choke hold what's
that called where you kind of subdue the
guy's submission hold you know and
Daniel Perry then just Penny post pair
was the guy in Austin who was approached
by the guy with a rifle and shot at him
yeah so this and but this is it uh
that's masculine there are people many
men who complain that men are disposable
and it's like absolutely not but but
technically yes it is not not disposable
as a whole but as individual as
individuals the question is
would anyone disagree is it better
that Penny knowing the consequences of
what would happen to him
moved to save those people or should he
as should he have just stood back and
said I don't want to go to jail let him
suffer
being a man is when you run into battle
that's right to fight for what you
believe in and save everything you love
and hold dear knowing you may never come
home it's running into a burning
building knowing that this could be the
end for you
but it all goes back to uh the the it's
biology evolutionary biology creates the
gender roles uh if you have a hundred
men and 100 women in a society and 99
women die that's it you're done your
tribe ceases to exist you cannot have
more babies
if 99 men die you will be in trouble but
you might be okay there could be some
inbreeding challenges in a future
Generations
but it's still not even that bad it's
not good but it's not that it's not as
bad as having one woman who can only
have a baby every nine months when you
have a hundred women and one guy that
guy's got to work really hard you get a
lot of avocado yeah he's uh Nick
cannoning out you know but
mathematically you can recover from that
if if all of your men die and that's
that's that that's the reality that men
can run into battle and sacrifice
themselves and your civilization can
survive because of it but if women
sacrifice themselves your Society is
over there's even that phenomena where
like a bunch of men are born after War
you know but we do have to go super
chance we went a little long let's go to
super chats if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
if you like it head over to timcast.com
where we will continue this conversation
in the members only uncensored show and
uh probably get a little spicier and not
so family friendly with it and then we
will take all of your calls as members
not all of your calls maybe five of your
calls but that's about how much we do
but uh for now we will read your super
chats
Clint Torres says howdy people that's
right Clint you are the first person to
Super Chat congratulations good job do
you get a prize uh just I read a Super
Chat and just honor you know what I mean
uh some bragging rights yeah it's like
you should get about 10 pool points yeah
you know there you go a hundred points
to house Torres congratulations
Australia is not real just ask a flat
earther says just trying to be the first
uh second place sorry
Tim P remember not me personally says
join timcast.com for access to our
awesome Precast pregame on the timcast
members Discord as well as Collins and
the Discord after show hashtag Bert I
CED court is so cool I I don't
understand how to use it but they have
so much going on there it's like a
little city it's a whole city I think
it's everything and and I want to make
it a point to keep shouting everything
that the community is doing out um
because I say like hey if you send it
become a member you can watch the
members show it's like well actually
join the Discord and there's a lot a lot
of stuff you can do and all the members
are building things and it's amazing
there's a pre-show there's an after show
there's various Chats on different sites
there's even like a women's Bible study
like they've got all kinds of I'm pretty
sure I could be wrong like they do
everything and I think this is cool and
you'll love this one we're opening a
coffee shop and we're going to be doing
what's called Saturday morning cartoons
oh really Saturday morning we're going
to play
family approved cartoons educational
stuff uh depending on the age of the
kids on average it'll range from like
you know very simple agency making the
cartoons yourself no but we could
theoretically use daily wire they have
uh program yeah and then there's Tuttle
twins yes and uh what we do is we're
gonna bring catering breakfast maybe
like 7 A.M Saturday mornings and the
idea is that parents can come with their
kids hang out have breakfast Everybody
Eats the kids can play with other kids
and socialize and the parents can meet
other parents in the neighborhood and so
it's a it's a uh it's trying to create
like half of what church was for people
to build community and meet their
neighbors and and you know I've been
studying you Tim Poole oh have you yeah
I have I had a good friend of mine a
young 15 year old named Titus who's a
huge fan of yours do some reconnaissance
and put together a rap sheet he put that
together so you knew that already no uh
he gave me all the other stuff but I've
been listening
listen of the idea of your franchise not
franchise coffee shops and I love the
idea of the community and I love the
idea of the alternative culture that
you're building and I just think it's
great I think it's great we uh I I my
goal right now the mission is to create
the Public Square yeah and that is
anti-time square
Times Square was named for I think it
was times of the world the New York
Times basically this that it's it's
elite as they come the big owners of
this big building and they control you
know like they get the name of the space
and now it's this big commercial
multi-billion dollar thing
we want to create the anti-time square
and it's these business so I'm looking
at so it was Ian's idea he was like we
should call it the Public Square and I'm
like let me ask Public Square how they
think like what they think about it
they're super excited yeah someone on
Twitter actually mentioned that that
wasn't my idea yeah and so uh I'm trying
to set up a meeting with them I'm like
imagine there's just this downtown in a
small town in West Virginia where you've
got cousin T's Diner Papa Jack's Pizza
Shack Casper coffee you got a my pillow
store insert a digital billboard we got
to get a big digital billboard
Square we'll just run Public Square ads
on it wait we can get a billboard
somewhere and try and figure out how to
do that but it's so cheap now but
there's laws as to what we like here's
here's the thing
we don't want to actually make Time
Square it's gross we want a place for
Community to be built and the people
that there are there are family Legacy
businesses in Martinsburg and they're
worried about what's happening with the
city they're like you know okay so my
pitch is
if we are to come in and set up these
businesses it must be that the existing
businesses that are generational family
businesses are protected and effectively
where need be subsidized and I think
that's actually a big draw so when you
come to this place and you're like I
want to go to cousin T's Diner next door
is a third or fourth generation you know
tailor shop or something maybe we should
start working on a parking deck too
parking parking because if it gets it
will get popular wow
we we we have plans but again
underground parking the goal is to make
it popular but not
overrun like Times Square we like it it
still needs to be to a lower degree but
meaningful so we're we're gonna be doing
the planning for this but imagine a
parallel economy small town Times Square
that's that's amazing what I'm hoping
for the monorail yes my dream it's one
all right we'll grab some more uh waffle
Sensei says yes Bobby Biden banged his
brother's widow but in his defense his
dad married the babysitter when their
mom died
she's a babysitter Joe Biden was no
children make stories about this Jill
she just plays on media uh no she's she
has her educational doctorate and I
heard this story that he like saw Jill
Biden's picture while waiting for the
train she had done like some small town
modeling and he saw her whatever and
that's that's how they met and then
other people have said this babysitter
thing but I don't know if that's true uh
she did I mean I think they did get
married they got married at the uh
Chapel at the U.N in in New York which I
think is super weird why would you get
married there if you're from Delaware
Sacred Space yeah I mean I do think you
know we were talking a little earlier
about like losing parent versus if
you're if your family is divorced and uh
I think it's always complicated to bring
a step parent into any any situation but
especially in that scenario when they're
so young and the media will allude
occasionally to tension between uh Jill
and Hunter or John I don't know if she
has tension with her daughter Ashley but
uh it's not not an easy thing although I
will say I think it is easier when you
your parents aren't divorced because
there is less uh you feel like you need
to be uh the Loyalty or yeah I know yeah
yeah yeah no Blended families are really
tough they're very complicated yeah is
this something that you get a lot of
questions about with your because I
assume your kids are growing up in a
liberal City I mean kids everywhere deal
with friends who are whose parents are
divorced well we deal with it a lot in
our work because we talk about the
importance of biology in the
parent-child relationship and how
complicated it is and honestly um how
there really is no alternative family
structure that involves unrelated adults
that increases the likelihood a child is
going to be safe loved thriving they
there are fantastic heroic individual
exceptions but the addition of an
unrelated mother or father figure in the
child's life will always diminish child
outcomes wow
I saw something about abuse physical
abuse in the home and how a lot of it
correlates with an un blood related by
blood yeah parent like step parent
stepfather live-in boyfriend uh yeah
statistically the most dangerous place a
child can find themselves is in the home
of an unrelated man left to care for the
child himself so likely mother's
boyfriend uh without a doubt
unquestioning there is no negotiation
about that all right let's grab some
more we got citizen seven says Tim the
most egregious lie Joe Biden has ever
told and told repeatedly was that his
son Beau Biden was killed in Iraq the
guy's a monster
yep he's a piece of garbage for those
that are super chatting asking about
last night's episode it's available on
all podcast platforms easiest way to uh
to find it iTunes Spotify Etc it is not
on YouTube and for that blame YouTube
uh YouTube didn't take it down but
YouTube has uh their issues so it is
what it is all right let's grab some
more Super chats what do we got
Terence Max says my mom has Alzheimer's
one of the key features of that is total
denial
she refused to acknowledge her Decline
and insisted she could do everything
just as well as in her 30s yeah it's
true yeah
it's hard it's hard parenting your
parents I have a friend whose dad was a
very serious libertarian and he's has
Alzheimer now and she actually finds
that to be challenging because you know
there's obviously things he doesn't
understand but they'll say things and
he'll say I have rights you know I have
freedoms you can't take this away from
me and it's a very weird to argue
someone with Dimension who apparently is
also a Libertarian because they're not
happy about it they have rights I would
not say Alzheimer's has a cure according
to science but there are studies where
THC will consume and inhibit the
formation of the amyloid there's a but I
I don't like any of that stuff because
there's a million and one things and
there's a bunch of different articles
and everyone's always making claims
about it check it out sciencealert.com
THC all assignments you'll find lots how
about just talk to a doctor and don't
listen to podcasts because they'll give
you pills I'm telling you otherwise but
there are but but this is like dude and
and I read from some hippie website
about you know tree bark has things in
it and then people go to burning man I'm
not I'm not a fan of I'm not a fan of
that anyway Let's uh read this we got
The Woodsman 1983 says the Secret
Service most likely wouldn't allow
anyone near Joe except medical
professionals if they did and something
went wrong Secret Service would be
responsible I what I find entertaining
about my hypothetical conspiracy theory
is that people are assuming that if the
Deep State orchestrated a hoax to prop
up Gavin Newsom the Secret Service would
be like oh gee golly we're gonna have to
adhere because we're not part of this
plan like I am literally saying in the
conspiratorial world of the the
intelligence agencies colluding on a
hoax to prop up gavinism the Secret
Service will not stop him from engaging
in the hoax they they planned themselves
that's why I'm saying I don't think it's
likely I'm just saying it's the perfect
scenario for them if they were capable
of doing such a thing
all right
where are we at
super jets
Jason Hutchinson says the state is the
god of the statists
so the the issue I think that is
confusing for people when it comes to
the issue of God is that they're using
God to refer to beliefs instead of God
but the problem with God it doesn't make
you good just believing in God does not
mean you could a lot of people do evil
in the name of God because their God was
better or they thought it was better or
something the demons believe in God and
shudder so
people people so the left may have
um
some kind of social structure that's not
God
there there is a difference between
having a moral framework believing in
God having a social framework and no
moral framework and so I'll describe it
as this I view the right as a mix
between people of a traditional American
moral framework which overlaps with the
Christian moral framework why because
they're rooted in the same things
there are people who have drifted away
from religion no longer believe in God
but they still hold a a the American
judeo-christian moral framework people
like Bill Maher friends all the time the
left has no moral framework and no God
at all they have social structures those
social structures
the facts don't matter
all that matters is their social blob of
chaos gains power and they adhere to it
that's why they're they're that's why
women sin becomes the inoffensive War
but then becomes offensive the next day
there's no logic logic is a material all
that matters is you you are in a you are
in a swarm of wasps and you don't go
against the Swarm that's it that's
because you're made for social
connection and even though this is sort
of amorphous and always changing
um it does offer you the community that
you literally need it is one of the most
important human needs is the need for
connection the need for identity
Collective identity and you're right
that's what church used to offer that is
what right-oriented religion offers you
as well but it there is a faux religion
that the left is offering and they do
give you holy days and they do give you
liturgies and they do excommunicate and
they do give you a community and I I
agree that like wokeness is could be
referred to as a non-secular religion
but I think it's better referred to as a
cult because there's no moral framework
to what it is they believe if you go to
Christianity Cults have moral Frameworks
there's no holy book or anything but
that but I'm not saying Cults don't I'm
saying religions do yeah right so so
religions
have the the faith structures and
tenants that exist Beyond The Living for
the most part I think it's fair to say
uh Christians overwhelmingly there
there's you know different versions of
the Bible whatever but there is Christ
the left it could change tomorrow we
have no idea uh let me read the Super
Chat it's a good example baconation says
Tim is wrong that there is no
centralized structure to the woke they
are morally compelled to support any
Underdog Palestine racial minorities
Ukraine Explains It All no it doesn't
Walmart and Amazon are not minorities
are not underdogs Joe Biden and the
Democrat and deep state are not
underdogs they will adhere to whatever
it is the tribe dictates that's why when
Oliver Anthony's song came out and it
was a general blue-collar lament they
attacked him for it why because
conservatives liked it that's it the
only the only thing they have is we hate
what the right likes we love what the
right hates whereas people on the right
will debate and argue about these issues
Seamus Cagle and I will have a
discussion about the limits of abortion
and we will disagree and we are friends
and we get along the left says don't
know don't care I just hate you that's
it now you can argue that there are but
Tim there are a bunch of liberals that
don't think that way right that's called
the banality of evil you know that most
of them have no idea that Joe Biden did
the quid pro quo they don't pay
attention to the stuff they made the
argument during kovid that the
constitution has limitations and public
health is more important than the
Constitution and now you're seeing many
of these same people come out and be
like there's no Public Health exception
in the Constitution because they know
that the governor's move in New Mexico
was bad politically
if it helps their politics they agree
with it if it hurts them politically
they disagree with it there is no
Central structure to it it is that's
what the other guy said right their God
is the state and something has to be
your God it's not it's not the state
they don't have a god they don't know
100 plus anti-fogo and firebomb
buildings and trucks and they occupy a
government facility it is not even the
state there are there are elements of
the state they adhere to it's just a
swarm of wasps that's right because
antifa is anarchy right that's there no
they're not Anarchy they they don't want
any government involved I don't want any
government power they want that's not
true at all antifa are communists antifa
action is comes from the German the
militant wing of the German Communist
Party anarchists are more like Michael
malice who are anti-establishment and
believe in the individual the when you
look at antifa firebombing government
buildings that is not because they want
no government it's because they want
power and control so the state is not
their God because they will destroy
enjoy it but they're going to create
their own state right sort of it's just
their cult it's like it's more like Isis
borders don't matter the the belief
structure doesn't matter all that
matters is they are a swarm of wasps and
you are in it and if you turn against
them in any way or are wrong you you
apologize and stay with the Swarm or of
course correct or you are out
so yeah so you you have all of so first
we have intersectional feminism
then we have critical race theory that
we have critical gender Theory it just
keeps changing whatever it is their
focus is randomly they come out and they
say why is the right so concerned about
you know child sex change operations and
it's like because you are pushing it and
defending it they say that you know
these things don't happen all that often
listen if a drag show happens where they
let children come in and this is like
sex clownery I think it's it's how you
like they it's clown makeup and it's
sexualized
yeah no the conservatives aren't saying
it's the end of the world if the
apocalypse saying hey I don't think you
should do that and then all of a sudden
the mecca the the the machine of the
left for no reason comes out and defends
these books like genderqueer and this
book is gay we get people in here like
the woman from majority report who
cannot cannot reject this book I say hey
they shouldn't bring books into schools
that show pornographic depictions and
teach kids how to do these things and
they're like I think it's a good thing
and I'm like there's no logic none
whatsoever it's whatever you are we are
the opposite it's it's like it's just
like an evil mirror version they they
attack the state they burn down police
stations they attack the White House
then they defend the state when the
state goes after their enemies it's not
for the state is not against the state
it is not for corporations or against
corporations they hate a corporation
they hate big Pharma they complain about
big Pharma when it comes to the price of
medicine but then all of a sudden the
vaccines come out and they're cheering
and singing their praises well not When
Donald Trump had them only when Joe
Biden exactly a really great Point
Donald Trump says we're gonna get the
vaccines out and they all come out say
no it's wrong and then all of a sudden
one day like a switch they all say
actually that was so weird because the
Democrat Governors came out and said
it's going to be mandated and they all
went oh are we doing this thing now we
will do thing it doesn't matter if it's
a state it just matters if it is their
Core Group exactly that's my point being
called Trump juice and then everyone had
Trump juice in their veins like two
weeks later and so I tweeted thank you
for letting Trump put his vaccine inside
you Trump is inside you forever now and
it will never never go away
that that that's ultimately like I I
there is no
there is nothing that exists on the left
in terms of a cohesive structure it is
just the antithesis of civilization it
is a chaotic and destructive force that
consumes and burns like fire there's a
lot of short order thinking probably all
over the place in any but within illegal
immigration I noticed it with the
immigration because I think people are
like the more if we bring more people
then we'll have more Community but
that's not how communities work you
can't just stick 30 people in the room
and expect that we all know each other
there is so much more to culture than
that and Community also they're not
thinking we'll have more Community
they're thinking we'll have more people
who will tip the scales in our favor
they'll influence uh census data so we
potentially could have more uh control
certain areas and maybe we'll eventually
get more voters although probably not
yeah I mean you can look like Sweden
like they didn't they didn't actually
have any of the people that were coming
into the country integrate into actual
Swedish society and they have these
separate societies within Sweden did you
see I wanna I wanna read this from Doug
blaskey says you've called them a cult
numerous times what do they worship oh I
love this what does it mean to be woke
wokeness is defined and as the as
adhering to the liberal social structure
the liberal social social structure is
amorphous but that's just about it there
there and I shouldn't even say liberal I
should say the political the political
and cultural view of what liberal is
you get all these people trying to find
welcome they're like wokeness is when
they you know go to schools and do this
and like wokeness is when they make all
the characters not white and I'm like
none of that is true
it changes from day all the time it goes
backwards and forwards but for some
reason it is always just destructive to
the structure of the United States I
view wokeness as very simply
the political cultural uh culture War
left as we would describe it
is fire and the constitutional republic
is on fire
so you're not going to sit there and go
but what does the fire want it's just
burning things down it is spreading and
consuming and starting more fires but
fire is actually about the carpet now
lots of things can burn and all that's
going to happen is it's going to keep
burning we must put the fire out we must
we must stop the radical ideology of
blind zealotry and restore the
constitutional republic
yeah
there we go yeah there we go salt
problem solved everybody agrees everyone
go home now but but I I think the issue
is I've been seeing this since the
beginning of the culture War everyone's
saying that the culture war is one thing
or another my favorite is did you I I
remember a speech given by a prominent
conservative the culture war is
nationalism versus globalism and I'm
like no it isn't it you go talk to half
these liberals they have no idea what
you're talking about there's not even
that's not even a concept to them then
I've heard it's authoritarian versus
libert versus libertarian and I'm like
no it's it to a large degree perhaps but
there are certain things the right
absolutely agrees must be uh must be
within the authority of the government
and then there's certain things the left
thinks the the government should have no
Authority on it is it is just simply the
left tends to do things that are part of
the left it is it is circular logic it
is a a group of people you know what it
is they're ants right they create
pheromone Trails oh yeah and you can do
a trick where uh or or a phenomenon
occurs where if the ants make a circle
Death March yeah Death March where all
the ants will walk in a circle because
the pheromones keep pointing they don't
realize and then eventually they just
run until they die they literally I I
view the left as something akin to that
they're all just following following
each other to Nowhere yeah I mean it
makes sense because all of like they're
all of like the idea of the the core
ideas and I'm not saying it's all from
Marx it's just like the core idea of
saying everything needs to be
deconstructed everything needs to be
post-modern everything is post-modernism
everything gets taken apart taken apart
you get taken apart no true Scotsman it
just kind of continues to fall apart
it's like entropy all right everybody if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends and head over to timcast.com to
join our Discord Community where all
this really cool stuff is happening and
we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show to talk about some not
so family-friendly things and then not
take calls from you our members and
after that the members of the Discord
are going to have the after after show
so make sure you sign up today we look
forward to seeing you there you can
follow the show at timcastirl you can
follow me personally at timcast Katie do
you want to shout anything out
um this is great and you're great I mean
let me just say like I've been listening
to some of your culture War issues and
your irls and you're a good host oh
thank you yeah I listen to a lot of
podcasts and you do a good job of like
pulling everybody in and keeping things
moving when needed and I thought you
handled yourself really well oh thank
you I appreciate it well like
specifically you had that culture War
One about gamergate which I didn't know
anything about and the woman that was on
she didn't want to talk about gamergate
she just wanted to like bring up every
single thing that you've said anyway
yeah I just want to say good job I think
that that's you're navigating it well
and I understand I mean I didn't know a
lot about you before this but I've got
some people in my life that love you and
respect you and I love and respect them
well you've got some good people
following you so that's what I have to
say appreciate it what's your you have a
Twitter account oh yeah tell us about
yourself it's not what that was supposed
to be yeah no okay it was a mandatory
compliment but thank you for shouting me
out totally no I just I really like I'm
an Advil underscore Katie on Twitter
them before us Dot com is where you can
subscribe to see my children's rights
work which is going to trigger you so
don't go there unless you're ready to
like do really hard things on behalf of
kids because that is the Mandate
honestly for every single adult is to
bend and do hard things because the only
alternative is for kids to do hard
things for you and that is a recipe for
Injustice and go to wherever books are
sold and Order raising conservative kids
in a woke City because uh the only hope
is I mean we're already having more kids
my liberal friends have zero to two my
conservative kids have two to twelve
kids and so if you can not just make the
babies but raise the babies we are going
to be in a very different place in this
case in a couple decades let's talk
about that the members only okay yeah
that'll be awesome I love this
conversation it's been so fun to have
you here I think your work is great uh
I'm hankler brimlow I'm a writer for
timcast.com you should go to timcast.com
click on the read tab to see all the
work from uh me for Chris Brown Chris
Bertman from Adrian Norman from all of
our journalists it's so fun to be a part
of that team I'm really grateful for it
if you want to follow me personally I'm
Hannah Claire dot b on Instagram and I'm
HC brimlow on Twitter and yeah I'm
excited for the members only show me too
can't stop it great stuff thank you for
bringing the mom energy uh oh follow at
timcast news on Twitter and Instagram
better follow Tim cast news thank you
Instagram and Twitter uh you can follow
me at Ian Crossland let's roll this one
out Serge yes uh I'm surge.com I'm not
gonna stay long do something to
challenge yourself today that'll be my
mission for you guys anyways see the
letter show we will see you all over at
timcast in about a minute thanks for
hanging out